day three of the 2020 u.s women's
championship
in an epic october for american chess
with the finish line getting near the
nation's best female players had to
raise their game
to stay in contention for the 25 000
first place prize
girls junior champion carissa if briefly
surged into the lead
but arena crush bounced back with a
blistering attack
and now stands just two rounds away from
winning her eighth title
it's due or die time as a new champion
will be crowned
the final day of exciting action coming
up next
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back as we
enter the final day of action at the
2020 u.s
women's championship i'm jennifer
shahady and i'm here with maurice ashley
and yasuo sarwan
as we crown a champion later today
yes we do jen hello everyone thank you
for joining us and sharing your day
for the finals of these u.s women's
championships
it's been a lot of thrills and spills
and leadership
leadership changes the only question
maurice that we have is
who's going to win and who's going to be
champion absolutely and we have
indeed a great champion at the top who
looks to try to continue her campaign
she hasn't won in quite a while and then
we have two chasers the young ones
looking for their first title this is
the kind of drama you want
going into the last day and let's take a
look at those standings jim
that's right we have irina crush at the
top with six and a half points
still two rounds to go karissa yip
coming off
a loss she has six points and some
much-needed arrests
dorset eric shawnee also is sick so the
champion very very likely to come from
this group of three but um emily nguyen
also having a good tournament
absolutely and our formation and we've
got a 12
player round robin with um
11 rounds so this is our fourth day we
only have two games today remember it's
a game 25 with a five second increment
and we have a hundred thousand dollar
prize fun there will be a tie break if
there's two people
tied at the top at the end of the day
let's see
how that will look we'll actually play
a two game rapid match game ten though
so a very fast rapid match if you will
with a two second increment and if
that's still tied we go to armageddon
where there's no
increment at all
and if there's three players tied for
first well we'll show you that later
but for now let's take a look at the
players
past and future in the storied event
indeed and we have a great list right
now
as three players have simply separated
themselves from the rest of the pack
and we're betting that it's going to be
one of these three who wins
the event i think the math says it's
probably impossible for everybo
for anybody else to win or a minuscule
chance but it's all about
arena crush karissa yip and dorothy
durashan you see there
six and a half and six points that's a
point ahead bottom person from the rest
they are definitely eager to win
their two games today and potentially
win the title well let's start first of
all at
the player tied for second or one of
them and that is dorset derek shani
you see there that she had that loss in
round two after
a nice start with a win but since then
she hasn't dropped a single game
draws with wins sprinkled in some of the
spectacular variety
a great score for her right now
she'll be looking forward to playing her
next two opponents
seeing whether or not she can actually
pull this off and
not so bad she's playing talia cervantes
and also tatev abrahamian tatev will be
a tough one in the last round
no question about it we'll see whether
or not dorsa can rise
to the occasion the next player who
really feels like
at any moment she's going to win her
first championship
is karissa yiff she started off with
three draws
but look at the middle portion where she
won four
out of five three in a row at one point
but yesterday's loss must have left a
bitter taste
in her mouth and that pulled her out of
first
place now without destiny in her hands
but she could still go for it she's got
a tough one
anna zatonski who's actually tied for
last at the moment talia cervantes as
well not doing so great
so we see a good chance for carissa if
her
opponents keep their poor form which you
can't control anyway
but speaking of control we have a player
who can control our entire destiny right
now
the seven time champion irina crush look
at her
line score this is how you win
tournaments people four wins
five draws if she can pick up a couple
of wins now
she ends any discussion and she will win
her
eighth title but will she be able to do
it against these two players
sabino foyser also not having a great
tournament
sabine of course a pass champion so it's
going to be tough
as will emily nguyen who has been doing
great and still has
a nice solid score there irina though
can she do it she hasn't won
in four tries after she was just picking
them up
easily but it's gotten tougher you know
she's excited guys
everyone's excited to see whether or not
she can close in on destiny
just two behind the record of giselle
aggressor
we'll see if she can make that one after
this day it's been an elusive victory
for sure maurice and let's take a look
at the round 10 pairings jen what do you
have in store for us today
well there's that crucial game between
sabina fueger and irina crash
as well as anna zatonski and karissa yip
and talia cervantes against dorothy
darrell connie so to saint louis
locals facing off but um check it out
all the front runners have the black
pieces
in rapid the disadvantage of playing
with black is not that severe but
still we've noticed in particular
players like irina and dorsa
are just dominant with the white pieces
a little bit less so with carissa
but um they really play magnificently
with white can they do it as well with
black
we'll find out in a few minutes when the
round starts but let's take a look at
the prize fund as well
because one thing you'll notice when we
looked at the standings early it's very
bunched up nobody has um that few points
the the bottom score is actually three
points right
so that's not too bad everybody's had a
win
in the game um everybody has a lot to
play for today that's the conclusion yes
a win can
skyrocket you up several places in the
standings
and money as well yeah that's very
meaningful
the money at stake and a very big shout
out thank you very much rex and genie
and the st louis
chess club with a very very generous
prize fund
as we take a look at our picks i was
doing great
from day one i just want you all to
remember that day one annie is doing
really great
at the beginning but um yeah tata is
mathematically still maybe
a chance to tie but uh oh realistically
um
maurice's pick right now who's the
favorite irene across and chrissy you
packed point behind
um definitely still in it as well had a
really tough game
yesterday against rita's warren so the
uh the sleep was well timed for her i
think
the wrestling you know yeah this october
championship
you've been on a bit of a roll jen i've
got to tell you
just to remind everybody you picked john
burke
in the u.s junior and that was a
scintillating choice
as it did come down to a tiebreaker and
armageddon
and john was our new champion and then i
picked old benjamin correctly as well
so i think you know can i get three in a
row well right now i think
maurice's pick is looking the best of
all because sabine has been very rocky
i do think she's another case of
somebody who's been particularly rocky
with black
she actually had a couple nice wins with
white we didn't really get a chance to
look at them
as much because they were in rounds
where other crazy stuff was happening
but she won a gorgeous game with white
against anna
so that's the good news but i still
uh irena's got to be the favorite in
that game regardless of color
yeah i would say so but anything can
happen and we see here
the new v chess look i'm loving it
look at that that's beautiful from board
level
that's looking quite grand right there
boy
that's a nice look chess piece is larger
than life
right that's like kind of the star wars
look and there you see when you're way
down
at the bottom of the board you kind of
got that jumbotron
uh image of the players on screen and by
the way
you see little increment improvements as
the chessboard also has
the lettering and the uh
numbering it's going to get better and
better it only gets better better on
here
well done well done to our technical
staff
fantastic job guys uh two big thumbs up
from hilversum holland yeah i love it as
well
it's just great to have different ways
to present this beautiful game
as i i know a lot of people speaking of
um beautiful game i know a lot of people
are very excited this week about
um queen's gambit which um just debuted
on netflix and
it's just such a sumptuous portrait of a
female chess
champion and will uh sabine be playing
the queen's gambit right now probably
not because irena's playing
g7 g7 g6 says the game
uh penultimate round underway and
uh we've been seeing a number of the
bishop
f4 lines and
um uh gets the senior championship mr
entertainment was playing like knight c3
d5 bishop f4
uh but uh sabine has just gone for the
standard bishop g5 no london
system so far and i'm expecting
knight d2 sometimes with the idea of
playing e2
e4 you say standard this is not exactly
your main line
way to beat the king's indian no not to
beat the kings indeed
it's almost i i use this not to a great
effect by the way the game was a draw
against dr john nunn dr john nunn was a
notorious
king's indian fiend if you will and he
worked
incredibly hard on his king's indian and
so
i would i would always be looking for
those
side variations and it was almost like
you need a great reputation
as a night or player for example then
everybody avoids the main lines
right and then you can just focus on the
side variations and
john seemed to know exactly where i was
going to go on the side variations and
and uh he stymied he stymied
me very well when i did that but here we
have knight b
d2 and arena has to decide right now if
she wants to play like
castles e4 d6 and it
it it's more of a perk defense and maybe
in that case sabine is al foxter in the
openings
or if she wants to play d7 d5 to stop
e2 e4 and then they get into like i say
it's not really a london system i don't
know what you call it when the bishop's
not on f4
when it's on g5
okay let's just go around the horn and
just take a quick look
gander at the game between anna and
carissa
anna zatonski white again carissa yet
coming in
tied for second in this penultimate
round has the black pieces
as you mentioned jennifer everybody has
the black pieces amongst our
leaders let's just see how they got here
by the way anna
doing something oh by the way uh
uh catalan no uh c5
and the invitation by the way to a
bononi but since you haven't committed
yourself to c4
that would have been an interesting
challenging decision ana
decided to duck it and play c3 e6 bishop
g2 bishop b7
queen b3 okay that's definitely off the
beaten track as she's
very looking to maybe intimidate her
opponent and say look
i'm threatening you with the harsh
d4 take c5 uh what are you going to do
about it
i don't like that queen on b3 at all i
don't
it's not a favorite is it actually
d it's it's kind of it's kind of cagey
because
it doesn't just threaten takes on c5 it
also threatens knight e5
looks quote-unquote threat right
right so if you made a knight g5 as well
if you made a move for example like
knight a6
uh to defend the c5 what you're saying
at maurice is like
hey i've got a threat of mate and one
deal with that but i've also got a
threat of bishop takes b7 deal with that
and if you play anyone like b5 like
you might find yourself in in
a real world of hurt early
so i hate this vision yeah that's
intriguing it's a sneaky
not only that what's sneaky about it is
if you decide to just resolve the
central position with pawn takes
on e on d4 95
could still land on the board
or i'm not sure which one is the better
one knight g5 or knight e5
but it's gonna have to be your same
response d5
and white might argue i shut out your
bishop
your bishop is probably not happy i'm
going to put knight c3 and
bishop g5 matter of fact you could even
play bishop g5 as a sneaky move
there as well whoa is that is that
possible d5
and bishop g5 on this move to try to
really make you suffer
because i don't think you could take i
don't think you would take on c3 now
would you
no i think that um has been played about
50 times by some strong grandmasters
and queen c8 um helping to
uh cover up some of those brutal
discoveries
is the correct move as chris now
knight e5 we can actually i think just
take on g2 and
run run run exactly you don't have any
follow up here you just lost a piece
maybe even worse than that but
absolutely queen f7
queen s7 would really be uh getting your
hand caught there in the cookie jar
queen ta
shout out to varusian for that insight
on the 50
uh move 50 games uh 50 by the way
you know you made a point to me to us
earlier
yes you said anna looks like this is in
the conversation we had that anna looks
like she has not
she's not as deeply prepared as she
usually is
right she's not playing that fresh chest
we don't used to seeing anna zatonski in
last place
and actually she hasn't won a game yet
you made this point jenna i don't think
she's beating anybody oh you might be
right
she has she's one who had a lot of draws
yeah yes i mean she
she hasn't beaten anybody so we're not
used to seeing this but what's bizarre
to me is
queen b3 play 50 times clearly
preparation then something that
is well known carissa took some time to
play what is the top move queen c8
and it took her some time so maybe she
was caught out there and she
said okay it looks like i have to deal
with these threats and queen c8
looks like it does the job wouldn't
or shouldn't anna be playing instantly
right now like you okay you played the
best move
and this is what i'm supposed to do
right i mean yeah
if you respect this i'm ready for your
top
move maybe she has been showing this
time and time again that she's
she's getting into time pressure all the
time in positions where she's very
we're seemingly prepared maybe he has
some issues with the memory
because you know irina pointed out
yesterday you have to prepare for a lot
of opponents in these rapid games it's
not just one
although today it was only two uh but
still
not knowing exactly what your opponent's
going to play and getting moves maxed up
i mean people have different levels of
memory and even
really good players sometimes or have
bad memories and that's why they
sometimes play
offbeat stuff right right like anna
generally doesn't play the sharpest
lines
um very very smart people can have bad
memories it's not like a direct
relationship
right right yes by the way
for somebody who doesn't really need to
win with black look at this game
i see you pulled it up yes yeah uh arena
crushes she's hunting down
this dark square bishop uh with the
moves
hxg5 and knight h5
again if you're playing with a london
system you your bishop gets
out of touch by having the h2 hatch to
crawl out of
and uh from arena's point of view arenas
in my opinion playing this ultra
aggressively this move c65 here uh
that i've played this position a lot as
black
a lot and i almost never play c5 in such
positions instead i usually play
knight to d7 i then follow it up with e6
queen e7 and very very slowly i decide
which side of the board am i going to
castle king side or queen side i don't
make that decision early
but i really don't like opening up the
position with this move c7 c5
because after d takes d takes at the end
of the day i'm left with a bishop
that well you know it's kind of biting
on granite
on this diagonal and i'm always afraid
that by the way that queen b3 move right
that my opponent is going to be the
first to put a rook on the d
file and gain an advantage against me so
i'm not a big fan of the move c5 and
sabina said okay i like that move let me
take it
and irina said let me take the bishop i
think arena felt that she was obliged to
do that
because otherwise bishop e5 i agree yes
and
the thing that also concerns me is
irena's king where is
it's address because like suppose i'm
white here and i play bishop c4
like that's a beautiful square for my
bishop and
it'll really strengthen the idea that
you had a queen b3 if it comes up
and meanwhile if you castle to get out
of dodge well good luck with that
i'm playing 95. i'm not even calculating
it did nothing to calculate made his
mate you know i mean you got it
uh yeah no no no that that's why you
you you you don't really castle
again you're playing a lot of kind of
waiting moves uh
again what i was doing was without the
trade of c
pawns playing e6 knight d7 queen c7
v6 and only when i had really developed
everything and i could connect the rooks
by castling
did i choose to castle now you i i fully
understand that you like the move bishop
c4 and it's a good move jen there's no
question it's a great move in fact
the only reason i'm favoring queen b3 at
the moment
is because i'm so anxious to get my rook
on the d file where there's this
potential
uh discovered attack and you know
it makes it really hard for black uh
to to develop the bishop because pardon
me that arrow was supposed to hit the
pawn on b7
so arena well i would say
not happy out of the opening bishop c4
was sabina's choice
she liked your move jen yeah and um
you know we mentioned that sabine has
been playing a lot better with the white
pieces and she does seem like he's in a
zone here position's easier to play for
white
we need to castle's long uh potentially
and it just looks like fun to play for
white
so um nicely done so far by foisier
yeah but c5 let's let's really
settle into this position because if c5
is irina's choice for her to let this
happen
is is not that difficult for white
not i'm not decrying sabine and her
preparation
but you see c5 happening you said my paw
is sitting there on c3
what diagonal do you think you're
opening you're just it's just not
you're biting on granite you're gonna
need a b5 b4
to release your bishop that's not
happening anytime
soon and white's play is very
straightforward so
i'm surprised that irina chose this way
to play i think she thinks she has to
win
which irina normally doesn't play hyper
aggressively
and especially not in a setting where
she's got the half a point lead i think
getting a solid position with black is
what the doctor ordered and then
hopefully i'll play your opponent from
there
but this kind of crazy imbalance where
white has all these chances
this is cause it's gonna be risky
if i were her coach i wouldn't have sent
her this way uh-huh
let's uh check in on the game of talia
and dorsa because dorsa
is another one of those players tied for
second place and
it the very conventional queens
indian on the board knight c3 is
probably been played like 5 000 times
i'm not kidding
d4d5 the polyglyevsky sacrifice
that served left polygams he said well
in this kg move rook e1
basically saying to black go ahead and
make a decision
if you play c5 now i'll play d5 and
these variations work out very nicely
for
for um for white
so rookie one and then we saw the move
d5
and now knight e5 uh
opening up the diagonal on the bishop on
g2
and knight e4 well if
if white can play like this a pardon me
if black can play like this
and make an easy balanced position
i'd be really really surprised
i've seen much much more often
especially robert byrne robert byrne was
really
a pioneer in this variation he would put
his knight on
a6 and play for c5 and
i suspect there has to be something
wrong
with this line of play for dorsa
and it might just involve the fact that
this pawn is a little bit too
far like something like this
and just saying a gift meet upon might
be
one of the reasons why robert byrne
avoided this
maybe var will be able to give us some
advice but
something suspicious about dorsa's play
hmm yeah well this is a st louis
um game as we see talia is actually
playing from where we're
usually commenting from guys exactly the
saint louis chess club the studio there
it was switched up there yeah she says
it's nice and quiet i spoke with talia
she says it's nice and quiet she likes
the ambiance of the club as people their
rooting are on
and there you get a nice look at our the
backdrop of our studio i miss it
i miss the studio as well yes we
certainly do without question
by the way take a look back at this game
between anna zatonski and karissa yip
that one is proceeding in the opening
with real
dynamism and it just feels like carissa
makes one false step and boom
she could lose castles bishop g7 let's
note that bishop g7 the tactic of
being able to play knight e5 returned
because now the bishop on g7 would hang
right so she had to be mindful of that
uh as this tactic could play itself but
she still looks like she's okay with
with uh
playing the move bishop to d5 and this
is her stopping point so this move
stops it all saves her and everything's
okay so now we see bishop e3 though
thanks for the tempo your queen has
moved twice and i'm hitting it
in so it's going to move a third time
and now it's going all the way back to
c8
so from what i've seen there's a trade
on c5 and white has gained a couple of
moves by
by being able to play this bishop e3
queen back to c8 now white gets to make
yet another move
does that val give value to her position
however
her queen is not necessarily the best
piece in in the world
and her knight is not going to find the
greatest square on d2
as its future is not so great black does
have those extra center pawns
as well so maybe this is going to turn
out just fine
for black i would think that carissa
would be
happy about the imbalance that is taking
place so for example
after a move like c4 and you kind of
start to look
say well this is a more conventional
morocci
kind of looking bind but then you look a
little further and you go well wait a
minute knight d7 knight c5
you know one of your extra tempes that
you might have won as white as having
your queen on b3 and in the meroxy
frankly the queen doesn't belong on b3
you'd much rather have your queen on h4
or d2 so i don't think that's the issue
now when i see this bishop on e3 what do
i see
i see a pawn i want to take that pawn i
want to take the pawn
really really badly bishop takes b6 a
takes b6 kind of
puts a damper on things so if
if there is a chance of getting some
kind of
play or pressure if you will on the
queen side it may be connected to a move
like a2 a4 so
something like this i could maybe sign
up for
as white and say okay i've got something
a little pressure and maybe my queen
will slide over here to a3 one day
uh still very hard to say that white's
getting anything
she played it concrete she did play a4
my concern
is black's natural knight to c6 does
stop that
and also threatens and knight c6 has
been played
and also threatens knight a5 to c4
herself
at some point so she's turning the
tables a bit
uh so now tonight a three on the board
night eight three i mean play is getting
very exotic
is what i understand white's play looks
slightly disjointed while blacks play
castles and can get a couple of moves in
or even just one move i
don't think black's gonna feel badly i
think white's working
yeah white's play has a little bit
unnatural feel about it
the bishop in front of the pawn on e2
the knight on a3 it's not like these two
squares are necessarily
good secure squares so
it does have a little artificial
artificial flavors to it i i mentioned a
moment ago
that maybe the queen would be better
placed on h4
so instead of a rook d1 move maybe
queen b3 to c4 with the id
yes news huge news started on a wrap the
big sacrifice alert in irena's game
versus sabina is sabina sacrificed on
gfi
oh oh whoa back it out
is irene looks like he's on the run
she's on the run yeah i like that she's
on the run for her eighth championship
is
um sabina just like queen h5 she is down
a piece at the moment though
um queen f7 and queen h8 the
simultaneous threat um
this i suspect is what you meant when
you said she's on the run that she's
going to move her king
to protect her bishop get out of the f7
threat
say go ahead do your worst capture a
pawn capture upon
and if i can get if arena can get her
king to safety
well she's the one to piece up what's
going on that's what i'm trying to
figure out like
how you do get to castle i think she's
seeing herself castling and
and being able to move her knight and i
wish i had a great
square for this night but i
i just see material coming back she
played bishop f6
i don't know guys i don't like that move
i also think this is long-term
compensation for white regardless guys
because think about it i'm going to
castle
say you move your king to c7 and i
castle queenside i'm gonna have
two pawns that's why she played bishop
f6 because i was thinking i was gonna
get three pawns in some of those lines
and then i'm like
okay you're a little discombobulated and
i have three pawns like how bad can it
be
but um maurice this move bishop f6
didn't strike your fancy
no i saw it but i was worried about
castles right now
uh instead of taking right away ah
because then she can't play king d7
right that was my worry but she could
maybe
hope and pray that she's gonna get out
of it with the move e6
and that might actually stop everything
because you can't take anything and
there's no good
night move i'm not i'm still not feeling
this
exactly as you know even in that
position there's f4
there there's a possibility of an f4
break uh
any combination it's two pawns it's a
very
difficult position for you to play if
you have
white right now and in this position
here f4 is what i was saying yes
f4 it's one punch
in this position it's one pawn the other
position you play was two
but in this one it's one but if i get an
e5
and knight e4 we're talking about
something very very different you this
if i could get one moving for you to
play e5 and you didn't take it with a
piece by the way
i have to consider that as well but
knight e4
will be the coordination that white
needs and black would be in serious
trouble because that knight's headed to
d6
and the king is stuck in the middle and
you have to worry about queen h8
that's all a combination of great
possibilities for
white so i am worried about that matter
of fact
no she's she's got to have to deal right
now she gets the material
or she castles that's her choices i it
will be hard not to take
f7 i'm going to tell you right now if i
were playing this game it would be
very very hard not to take on f7
yeah i agree maurice i think your move
castles is brilliant
but it's over the board you're like
you're looking clean f7
because you've got you know how often do
you have a chance to play queen takes f7
shack and not do it right
it's pretty rare
look look that up in the database when
do people not
play queen takes f7 check in the opening
bishop takes f7 too just because it is
true that if the queen f7 king d7 knight
e5
could be uh a threat soon so i can
imagine thinking about bishop f7 but
then
also thinking about castles you know in
a classical game
definitely we can see that in a in a
rapid game it's
possible but you have to kind of like uh
have this method of
thinking of candidate moves here
otherwise you're just going to get
tunnel vision for one of those
captures with jack yeah here i'm not a
big fan of bishop f7 it just feels like
you're going to give black the tempo she
may need to play a move like
h8 any trade of queens is extremely
favorable trade trade for the second
player
bishop f6 is a terrible move guys i mean
i'm just he has taken on
f7 with jack i gotta tell him
obviously i'm gonna get that one
forced moves are good moves uh yeah i
mean because you're gonna have to play
king d7
anyway and you know you're gonna have to
play king d7
full stop end of story so you start with
king d7 and then you ask yourself
well after queen f7 do i need to move
bishop f6 and you probably right
exactly no i i don't need that move i
could play
king c7 and i could play queen e8 these
may be better
choices bishop f6 is not the first move
and i think maurice you were mentioning
an idea f4 e5
if you put your bishop on f6 you're
encouraging right
yeah totally agree yes king d7
king d7 was necessary so might as well
have been played
the bishop doesn't know where it belongs
and it was fine on h8 it's going to be
defended
and so putting it on f6 first
just very good point very good point it
a lot it just
opens everything up for white and white
wants
to bring as much of the resources as
possible into the position
and f4 is going to be one of them that
bishop on a very bad square
this this is giving some compensation
that said the king's headed to c7
c7 is not a bad house to hang out on and
and if you can somehow get your bishop
developed
maybe the d7 and then the queen swings
white's attack is not super coordinated
and by the way the e5 pawn
i will say it's likely i kill that
sucker when it lands on that square i
mean
knight takes and then bishop takes
giving back the two pawns for the piece
exactly well right you know you've got
two so i'll take two
and and if my king is sitting on c7 as
long as i have the dark squared bishop
imagine that darshan bishop on d6 for
example right
let's talk kind of let's do a variation
pink c7 right now after castle
f4 f4 and i'm going to play bishop d7
just
just for fun well it's not it's not for
fun
it's just the fact that i'm going to be
moving my knight
and in anticipation of a
of a discovered attack you have to
um uh block the d file
all right so we were playing e5 winning
back our piece right so now now of
course
i don't have to give you the piece back
but i'm going to play knight takes
and pawn takes and bishop takes and i
would make
the observation that black
is under incredibly severe attack
white has sacrificed nothing like
material even right and exposed king
undeveloped rook uh this looks
great for sabine and sabine pardon me
and arena really under a lot of pressure
now
you could try to play bishop d6 and hope
that you know something terrible doesn't
happen but i
don't like yeah this one
i thought i would have a move here i
don't see my it doesn't seem like i have
a move let's go back
and by the way castles did happen king
c7 did happen
as well these are like kind of forcing
looking moves king c7 on the board
and we're just we're looking at the
straightforward f2 f4 and
with you know now that that now that
arena's bishop's on f6 sorry
maurice go ahead okay first things first
maybe
i need to capture your f4 pawn okay
and remove a target i need to remove a
target by the way we could throw these
moves in
whenever like uh gfgf
down the line down the road or as you
like yeah yeah let me just get rid of
this target okay now my bishop has to be
if i play bishop g4 you're going to play
your knight to f3 and i'm and that's a
tempo
but you don't have a check of any kind
so my tempo could be a counter tempo
something like does queen e8 trap your
queen
no you can play queen unfortunately
a very very desirable move by the way uh
if you could trade if you could force a
trade of queens we would stop
and say yeah the sacrifice sabina's
sacrifice isn't any good but queen
d5 does go away with the tempo
now however however in this position
you do have two pawns you're looking for
a third i could trade off
every all the major pieces of my your
attack is finished
but you do have three pawns for the
piece by the way um
sabine did play knight to b3 not the f1
right
to be three
no no thank you for that because uh
quite
understandably you know she said i
sacrificed a piece
if i can get three pawns the reason i
actually preferred f4 versus knight b3
was i like controlling this e5 square so
that
i don't face the consequences of a
knight move now
uh because of the tempo by the rook
let's assume that
arena moves her queen no actually if
erusian says that there's a winning move
for black here
knight e4 95 is what i was looking at
myself
ignoring out of rook takes v8 knight f7
i guess you could play
but you're still only going to have what
a pawn two no no just one two one
two ones but no no no no no no no no no
no no no you don't want this
short yeah
but i thought i was wondering about
queen h5
or queen h7 even just moving the piece
yeah the queen away but is there
we do have a piece in our pocket right
so also i just got to think about
taking on d1 and taking on c4
if we wish but we also don't have to
give anything back
no you've got to and she's founded now
she's found the move
95 on the board great defensive move
this you know f4 was needed we're seeing
it now
everyone was needed so that you didn't
play this and it also introduced more
pieces into the attack
the trojans famous quote he said when
you sacrifice play like you sacrificed
not like you lost material play like you
sacrificed it so knight b3 says i
sacrifice for two pawns
let me get a third and equal the
material no no
play like your sacrifice f4 you got a
piece i'm coming to try to get you
you better figure out how to defend and
she didn't do that
she instead played a knight b3 which
which tries to get the material back
and this counter shot intermezzo
zwissenzug
95 great move
boy irina was in trouble and yeah
get out of it like this she's coming up
roses guys
oh yeah well it's a nice nice moment
here
also for arena she would love to see the
queen retreat to h5 that would set up
the table
beautifully for bishop g4 you could take
the queen
now exactly at this moment it's a rook
and a bishop for a queen but guess what
the queen is hanging
the knight is hanging and the rook is
streaming
into the d1 square and it's winning for
black
so queen h5 is not even playable
no bishop g4 would win so
we need them so we're we're hearing that
karissa and doris are both struggling so
actually it's possible for irena to
clinton the tournament right now
depending on what happens with those
games
still a lot of play left in both but um
position is looking a little more
passive and doris is actually in a bit
of time pressure
well not a huge time pressure but she's
doesn't have a very pleasant position
and she's down on the clock most of the
games in this tournament we've seen her
ahead on the clock
um and yeah this was the position i was
talking about between anna and carissa
azana just lashed out with b4 and you
know we'd really
like to be able to play knight c4 here
but it's not good with so much control
white has over c4
and anna just looks to be pushing
carissa back
yeah she went e5 a5
and then we can go um c4 and
suddenly the position's opening up and
all of our pieces are ready for it
um the well geez jen i'm not
sue that unhappy is
black i mean the only problem i have and
i agree it is a problem because my queen
is actually
like i think this queen is not not that
great right the queen is on
a2 but at least it's out of the way of
attacks
where somehow the queen on c8 needs to
be out of the way so
28 or something maybe well it would be
brilliant if i could castle
uh you know my queen into rook
uh how would a line like this just go
because
b7 in such positions is really a kind of
an ideal square
[Music]
i'm feeling good for white boy look at
those active pieces
95 go forward well again i'm just
i just want to see it for sure like you
could take
and i could take if you take and i put
my queen on b7 i
i feel like somehow the storm
wait i went too fast that went too fast
it might have been a sacrifice on d5 or
well this is the current position and
we're looking this is the
i hear you that yeah i don't think
white's winning but it seems like black
still has to
try to find the neutralizing moves like
you're doing right
right i mean rook d5 here
rook d5 okay that's a good thing that
that rook is
actually protected well that's why i'm
doing it you're right
okay so let's see i take and then i take
knight c3 instead of knight e3 was
possible also
yeah i i was just trying to calculate
uh yeah the body count is i'm not
getting it i apologize i'm not getting
in
rook c1 if i could get and look okay
maybe is the move right okay oops excuse
me
that's attacking the queen right
now knight here knight takes 1897 check
it's a royal fort but maybe that comes
out ahead
yeah so you gotta take
but now i'm in the behind no no no oh
three pieces for the
for the two two rooks
[Laughter]
okay i'm back i'll take it i'm i'm still
not sure maurice because i'm not sure
either but it sticks
the rooks and that's going to show some
flow i don't know
this knight on c6 shuts down both the c
file
and the d file which is great from
white's pouring of view because
your minor pieces dominate the two rooks
but when you see a6 you go
oh the a file could be
uh money for okay
four let's oh no you have which one you
have you have a check on
e1 okay i need i need to put my knight
on a better square
knight probably knight d2 you have a
check on c1
yeah i want to play i want to move my
knight knight uh
let's do knight d2 because you're
thinking okay
so you could win
oops excuse me i picked up the wrong
minor piece
uh you've got two pieces for
a rook and a pawn in this variation but
i'm still
feeling that position yeah i need a
better nightmare
okay but this is five exciting stuff
this is crazy but
but the the thing is is anna as usual
uh taking burning a lot of clock and
i think guys that means that she's
looking at
she plays other things no she c4 she
played t play c4
okay sorry this is exciting stuff if c4
takes takes
is there a knight b6 that was possible
i'm sorry where now i'm taking quick
takes not now
rook takes d5 we gotta look at all of it
knight takes on b6 now i have what a
piece of the pawn
now you have you have okay with this
position what's
your looks for a queen for a queen and
exactly but again now the rooks are
actually
working your pieces are very active and
i can't i need a strong night move but i
don't have three socks
i could just throw it somewhere forward
then i'd be okay but i can't find
anything to do with it
so that doesn't that doesn't work out
dynamism is in black's favor
let's back up and takes on c4 has
occurred
so and i'm almost certain that after
knight takes uh carissa
is going to play bishop d5 now here
you're right maurice the move rook takes
d5
forces you to calculate goodness knows i
don't know how many lines
i went for the more sedate
call it a senior moment uh where i just
said played okay
knight e5 and i was i was thinking about
here now paul's right here because
right here is where we do have some
action that could take place for example
knight d6
so the idea is obviously i want to take
whoops i fell up a little short i want
to take your queen
now if i can just please get your queen
to move
then i'll recapture and this is good
this is good this is good this is good
a lot of good pieces for white uh
if you play bishop d5 now your rook d5
really looks great
no but but queen b8 yes queen b8
in that position no the moment you have
their knight on the position you're
disgusting okay
take take night on these days take
knight d6
here yeah in fact do you have a
discovery that i'm worried about if i
play queen d7
no i'm putting my queen on d7 i'm just
gonna go for it give me
yeah and if you now take what if i play
knight d5 here
knight d5
[Music]
i was dreaming i i was dreaming that my
rook
would somehow if i could
maintain my knight on the
d6 square i was dreaming that
it would dominate no followed by rook
yeah i'm gonna play rogue five i mean
queen a3 allows brook
bishop f8 right eventually rook d8
bishop f8 i'm going to take on
i don't even want to take anything uh so
here you could take and i don't know
i've got
active pieces but i got well what do you
have for knight c3 yes
what do you have for knight c3 if i
don't think if i fork you that old
knight
no no no no that that was uh
it was funny because i was going to play
queen a3 to sidestep the fork
and then it was like i didn't do it uh
and rook takes d5
no no okay insufficient by the way
i like what sabine did against irena
because going into that one of those end
games would have just been like resigns
right
sorry sorry jen just let's just clear
this up because
the fans want to know what did happen is
what
yasser is analyzing right now knight c4
because we were analyzing all the
variations
knight c4 did happen and rook c4 she did
not play bishop d5
she gave her opponent this extra tempo
so she can move his q
queen to e8 and she's looking at bishop
d5 now as a key threat
so that's that's where we stand now over
to the other game
absolutely i mean this is an arena crush
game yeah
i mean yes she's up a piece for um
just two pawns at the moment but oh my
gosh
queen h5 was played it was irena didn't
play bishop g4
uh i'm shocked i thought that that
because she would get a rook and two
bishops for her queen
after bishop h8 exactly and now
um that was a big time movement five
rook b8
uh how does it look f4
i know i'm allowing bishop g4 and if i
sneak in with queen a6
how how does that one go let's take a
look because i'm sure that's one of the
things that sabine is furiously
calculating right
no question you're trying you set your
material down you're trying your best to
make an attack
right no we're not giving you this
forget it i think this is going to play
bishop g4
yeah okay so you get that thing
let's just hold for a second hold for a
second i'm the i'm
an attacker like anybody else but i just
realized that the rook has gone off of
d1 in that line so let's see it bishop
g4
queen a6 right right so you're saying
after a bishop
and take the biggest problem the rook on
d1
get that off the board and now when you
take on a7 king d6
and how do you make any progress because
i have f takes e5
okay bishop takes it you take it hold on
now i'm only in exchange get down
i got you but you're king my turn queen
check
let's go check yeah let's go
you know taking on taking another one
with check let's go
and now nike too so then you no longer
want to take pawns even
nowadays coming to c4 well there's a
rook uh
guy on b6 that was a little too much
that was a little too greedy right there
[Laughter]
oh oh mistake mistake i played this
i played this like a knucklehead i
should have played e6 on the very first
move instead of checking
by the way sabine just played the quiet
move king b1
uh that feels like she's unlikely to get
away with that in this position
um i guess she was worried about like
maybe if she played f4 she was worried
about takes and queen h6 or something
like that
that's the other move i was looking at
in case this attack of this crazy bishop
g4 didn't work out
that that's possible as well and they
just now you have to stop and spend a
tempo
and bishop g4 is on tap and it looks
very slow
so that that's a solid enough reason to
not go for this line
i'm not feeling white's attack
i think that black is uh
too slow by the way isn't e6 possible
right now
yeah e6 looking good
what do we do
no i'm not feeling it if i have to play
bishop c4
that means that f4 is no longer any kind
of a threat because
all that does is force you to play
knight take c4 so
e6 if i play f4 this looks
pretty hokey
not to mention that you even get a
bishop f5 check it no
this is it it's it's it's
it's good it's just simply good for
black
and she's down to only 245 in the
position as well so
irina needs to stop and figure out what
she wants to do
that's just the right way and i think
this is hers
i think the title um she could be up by
a point or more guys is ana's got a
really nice position she's just
uh played the move queenie one fixated
on that e5
and okay there is potential discoveries
with the knight on d5
but honest clock though is a problem she
does only have two
and a half minutes that's like an
eternity for anna though
that's a luxury a luxury
curious isn't it curious that sometimes
it's just a position of one piece
a slight difference and if that queen
we're sitting on e7
you'd say okay it's a position we play
rook to e8 and you have a little
pressure
but okay i mean rook feat but the queen
on the eight
who defends the e pawn and the queen on
a1 you'd say what's a queen doing on a1
and look at this she decided to play
queen e6 and ditch the e pawn
so she can get some play we were just
talking about that queen and she
felt it she felt the the po the lack of
coordination in her forces
and now she's just going for it with
this queen move which by the way
she does have the little devious ideas
of moving her knight
off of d5 and hitting the hanging rook
on c4 that's something her opponent
will have to calculate this this move is
not one you want to see
with 220 left on the clock guys i like
it
even just for its hustle potential not
just for its
its actual accuracy but man you better
find a move
it's one of those coffee house moves
that
bet larson was really so very well known
for
uh everybody was would be expecting
the commentators would be expecting a
move like f7 f6
uh to defend the pawn on e5
here and queen
e6 sets up knight e3 now anna
didn't spend too long guys she said she
played knight
i've got an ig-5 where's your queen
going to go
now the queen should probably like to
eat 7.
hitting i suspect that
all you're doing is making your queen a
target if you were to
try to play aggressively uh with queen
f5 so
queen e7 very quickly came back and now
well coordinated move ana's got
bishop a3 on tap but the knight on g5
is hanging she could uh
was it
yes she did she played it h2h4 and she
says okay i've got bishop a3
uh what are you going to do about them
afterwards eight rookies
seems logical okay and
i assume anna is thinking that
she's the one with the initiative if she
can get in the move bishop a3
definitely i mean that queen keeps
dancing around
well like queen of six is the only move
i can find that makes sense right now
without losing material
right okay we'll have a knight e4 with
tempo when you want it
right and i'd like to keep that in
reserve at the moment
the rook on c4 is not making a
a glorious impression so let me withdraw
it
so i could set up for rook
c2 to d2 now if you play
h6 and i go knight here i go rook d2 and
knight d6 and carissa
no no we're not playing h6 your knight
can stay there what are we bothering
tonight for
please you know hang out we need to go
here's the coordination of our pieces
and that's the real issue and there's a
doubling on the back row
is there a bishop a8 ugly
just because i needed protected move
hate wasting time on moves
and then somehow move this knight on a
square
where
no i don't like this at all i don't
either but i i
i think uh i think i'm being slick but
what is happening what what are you
threatening oh you have to say
it takes f7 rook takes c7
big big big time take this and play
no i can't take on g2 because you'll
take
carissa is going to have to do better
than this let's go back now
what do you do though by the way um i i
got to tell you that
doris and derek shawnee's also in
trouble it looks like she's worse
um in an end game struggling to keep
material unbalanced so
actually irina could literally clinch it
this round as dorsa
and carissa both struggle i mean
she's got uh this problem that the pawn
on c7 is under capture
your back rank is weak so you can't just
play rook c8 not to mention the fact
that i could also just take on a7
um and on top of that if you play a move
like
c6 knight d6 is in the air so
she plus she only has 30 seconds guys so
everything
is very perilous right now for derek
johnny
that 30 seconds is probably the big deal
but i don't know if it's that bad right
now for her
taking on a7 and then if you rook a8
just back to b5 you have no time to take
on a2 because r28 is made
but when you take a pawn like that on a7
just make sure that your knight
does come back i mean you you you
grabbed a cookie
and i mean you inspired me yes well okay
okay but
maybe maybe you could say blame yes yeah
no no no
i i'll i'll take that as a compliment i
mean it's very very good i mean
because you do get to play rook d1 and
maybe
grabbing the pawn on a7 is very very
nice but yes sir what was wrong with d6
also in that position after c6 that that
also seemed to question
the position yeah if you
uh by the way because my king is under
duress
this is not threatening to win a piece
yet because you still have that
that tempo so yeah you you're probably
just winning or better
here with white oh pardon me uh rook the
eight-check
worthy yeah a little better a little bit
a little bit you get there however you
get there so dorsen big trouble
and arena did get the bishop on c4
she did she she chased it away with the
move e7 e6 as we suspected
and after bishop c4 she actually spent
us
a full tempo to give her opponent a move
wow very surprising
uh but again she's got
um two bishops two bishops against a
knight in two pawns
uh materially speaking she's dominating
uh
dominating if arena doesn't
hang something terrible like a knight c5
or a knight d4 whoa
but but what about e5 right now
and knight d4 is that annoying or do you
have an intermezzo
get the feeling you might have an
intermezzo
you mean something like bishop d5 or
queen g6
queen g6 i'm not she's played e5 queen
g6 i'm not as worried about
oh wait king yeah queen g6 i'm not as
worried about
but bishop d5 i am worried about because
it's a it's just a
free move tempo i want to get the knight
to b5 so
let's say for example let's just put a
move on the board bishop
sorry g7 oh my rook d8 i want to make a
bad move bishop g7
and let knight e4 half knight d4
happened 94.
now is is it the truth that bishop
d5 actually just says you might be still
good
knight b5 and the king just has to
sidestep
a check yeah i
don't believe it don't believe it it's
hype it is hype
so all right well if that doesn't work
and i and i made what i thought was a
bad move and you're finding moves like
rook to d8 or
potentially queen g6 yeah i think
the table was yeah the tape so if you
get some position like this this is what
i was thinking that arena
not only is she material ahead she's the
one who says hey wait a minute who's
attacking whom
the rook is streaming down the bishop is
streaming to d5
this looks and the grand master has
found it she's found rook v8
immediately says let's play chess your
attack is going
nowhere and it's going to be two bishops
against a knight
and we don't care how many pawns those
bishops
are vicious rook takes has been played
you play bishop takes now
and i mean those rooks are i mean those
bishops
they're killer bees for a reason you're
not doing anything with your knight
that's what's going to be game this
actually you could resign here
yeah comfortably without without problem
because
yeah that leads it to the game between
anna and carissa which is also
20 seconds left for anna but she has the
dominant position now guys as she's
clipped the pawn on e5
um what what's going on here carissa
rook takes me five played okay queen has
just recaptured
on e5 what does carissa have in mind no
idea where's the discovery well the the
queen d1
knight she was hoping for queen d1 but
bishop one is possible
oh no this is this looks terrible now
for carissa
simple move queen uh
c7 should just finish the game because
the bishop is hanging f7 is hanging
you've got to avoid the queen trade
which won again but bishop f1 and
you can take the knight sure but you're
losing the bishop on
b7 and you have to take it anna
has to take the night right now and then
take on age four and pray for rain
that's all you got left seventeen that's
it you gotta have to take a night
and then take on age four and hope you
have some some
psycho tricks we don't believe it but
she's done it
hg5 nothing to be done queen takes b7
and we would assume g5 takes h4 now
that's probably
this is the problem that i'm seeing
though is this check
and take this guy in ruro
because this is going to be mate
yeah i guess the rain didn't come i'll
take on g3
take on g3 in that position take on g3
oh sorry um i forgot that this is
this is actually check i was going to
play right here that's
actually a check on the board i guess i
have to well if i take
queen d4 and it's not over over
over and by the way she didn't
she did it in a different move order did
or
no same position same and i saw the bar
i saw the
the the evaluation bar just dipped
dramatically
on the board and queen f7 played
and the bar is now going equal and this
is the rain
that we were praying about taking on g3
and
suddenly tables have turned and she has
her time pressure and look at this queen
d4 how do you deal with
all the checks maybe there's a perpetual
in the position there yes that king is
very exposed e4 is dropping with check
and the knight could check anywhere this
is a draw
that that was the hustle she needed to
stay in it this is a draw your king is
not going anywhere different
as long as she dark square checks you
your bishop can't block
the knight will always play knight g4
you don't want to risk that
this is a draw amazingly it's it's one
of those things when
yeah it's retained when you're having a
i was about to say when you're having a
bad tournament even your winning
positions
you wander away i mean this was
oh i'm so sorry for anna she played she
played a nice game she really did
it looks like she just let it slip right
out of her fingers
times game versus door set and that one
could go any of all three ways
look who's trying to win look who's
trying to win she didn't prepare
she didn't prepare she is still trying
to win the game
yes carissa did not prepare she played
knight g4 in honest time pressure she's
looking for mates
we got to get back to that position oh
my god you're right you're right
she's looking for mate and is she gonna
get it queen g8 there's king h6
oh my gosh queenie one played
how'd this happen she just played knight
g4 and now
it looks like she has isn't bishop d4
and
and nasties look at the king position
it's terrible queen check and now she
can but oh queen takes g3 you have no
extreme
18 oh duh
she just played she should have taken on
g3 and she's
good this is good this is good she's
winning
carissa is winning it looks like with
knight
e3 and she's played knight e3 what do
you do
i don't know why why the engine bar is
giving 50 50
though in opposition i don't know there
must have been something magical because
i didn't see it it looked like you were
just losing it and see
it's hanging by the way so um because oh
my gosh
oh no
and what a turnaround oh my god
unbelievable
unbelievable and of course the win and
the tournament
is
oh
oh and she could have taken on on d4
with ch
taking on d4 and then played c5 with
check and she was completely winning
dorsey was completely winning by the way
the problem for dorsa
no she doesn't have that problem i was
looking at the broncolor pawn on
on uh on a one but that doesn't look
like
it's gonna relate no because she made a
different path but
uh what this still looks very close to
drawing
your tutorial i don't know what the
evaluation is here let's see
well king f4 and e5 is coming so yeah so
this is
very tricky the question is the timing
there if i can just
you know ram through with my my pawns
i don't think so and by the way you got
to worry about whites past pawn
white has a past a pawn coming and white
is inside the square
so here we go e5 on the board black
might lose this if she's not careful
is a4 too risky gosh dorsa was
completely
was oh my god was winning we're seeing
massive turnarounds as this end game and
king d5 is threatened
right now right now king d5 is
threatened you might have to play
you might have to play bishop f7 she's
played oh she's prepared to play c4 okay
king d5 anyway right yeah because you
can always go back
c4 takes takes king d4
right and you're you're just sitting
pretty easy
easy draw no loss possible there
we play bishop takes take your a pawn
and say let's leave
let's leave now well no but it was like
dorset was trying to win
oh oh what a try oh she
she was up a piece this is now drawn
lately winning just go back to the
moment we
we too we turned in right here
and what uh dorset could have done was
take
the rook followed by c5 check now you've
got to maintain
um protection of the pawn on c4 so
if you drop now there's no f4
yep night and day it's night and day
game over it's that simple oh and this
will be a draw
she's still in it with a shout but a win
would have been much better i cannot
believe what happened in the carissa
game
of course irina was up that material she
did liquidate down
into a winning end game up a straight
piece and forced resignation seems to
take more time
than necessary but she did get it but it
was this game
guys how anna lost this this was
pure street hustle in this game that she
managed
we said she had to take on g-force had
to take on eight on g5
had to take on h4 and see what happens
and
it the reigns came i mean in abundance
you know
winning this game and now only
a half a point out wow
and this is the end of the carissa yip
game
in v chess as we see it unfold
before our lying eyes guys this was a
great move queen e3
check we expected queen takes g3 but it
was this
move queen h6 check that sealed the deal
and then we were shocked that she didn't
take the rook
on c8 right here she played knight g4
well which he did worked out pretty well
too didn't it
well of course it did uh rook c2 wasn't
your hard topic
but uh yeah it was just what turnarounds
going back and forth there
maybe queen g2 gen instead of rook c2
would have
made life i always say what happened we
still would have had what
bishop there would have been bishop d4
and then knight e3 jackass
sorry i meant rook sees what rook c2
rook c7
oh you mean hold on instead of queen i
just say yeah
i put it on the 3d board for a second
and it was right here
where maurice and i were saying take the
rook
yes yes yes after this move
i mean okay yeah
it still might be winning for black but
no but it wasn't guys it wasn't winning
and we should get over to the other game
yeah who did have a defense we'll talk
about this right after
let's finish the game that's in progress
and we'll talk about it but white
did have a defense knight e3 was a
mistake i should say queen 86 was a
mistake
and 93 was not winning but we'll look at
it shortly cuz i just
just checked with the engine and it was
a mistake but what is this black oppas
exchange in a pawn this is busty
well whoa rook takes c3 she has not yeah
rook takes c3 check and rook a3 would
have just went on the spot
would have won on the spot but actually
it's funny you can't even really stop
that can you i guess you could play
rookie
three that's how bad your position is
you can't even stop that threat
and actually ricky iii is because you
can't move your only piece to move is
the
right
five and then oh but you she could play
rogue she played
g1 that's turned out and now with work
a3 you have rook c1
that's why jen's just putting bringing
her king into this is over
bring three pieces that night is gone
yeah
um totally winning as well
totally winning b1
good try yeah that's true rook b1
followed by king is coming to b4
yeah well she took the other rock yeah
here i would just give up the rook for
the night yep
i feel like the night comes to c3 i'm
taking that night i'm just taking that
take it right now yeah right right now
you got to go you got to go we play
candy there it is
of course she didn't hear you they they
don't hear the commentators
jennifer you uh it looks like that was
an emotive game we didn't get to see it
all
right let's go back to the other game
guys the moment
score for the first time in a little
while
anna was in trouble against carissa at
this finishing position
but look at this when she played queen
when she played
queen to h6 with check
so we got she got this far and she
decided i'm not going to take the draw
and right here she should play queen g3
check bishop h3 and knight e3
the problem is after knight to e3 the
queen could just move
not f3 but let's say f2 or g1
oh and then you have queen h2 and then
when you take just queen h2 thanks for
trading pieces
and uh hello why are we lost it's a game
it's a game it's a game rook c7 takes on
a seven is coming
so there was not a win her time pressure
made her
panic in that moment she should have
taken on g3 the movie that i expected
without any question just take
upon and be done so this was actually
too fancy for your own good yep and yeah
and says let's trade queens if you'd
like
because you can't because then you can't
travel anymore because there's queen h4
mating
nice nice nuance but hey i mean playing
on the increment
that's the problem it was just a live
wild ride there at the end and if we and
if we may when i said
you had to take on h4 and pray for rayne
i was right
because when you take on h4 white has
the winning move
and but all the threats look like
they're building but when you take when
the
takes happened in h4 e5 ends all life
e5 instead of taking on h4 just e5
and that's johnny ball game yeah because
you can't get your pieces into an attack
me now because nike four there's queen
c8
so e5 actually creates this situation
where your bishop is bottled in
because i move my pawn forward and your
knight is actually
more restricted and the rook defends
laterally
yes and the rook also attacks jen
because rook h4
enters into it as a check when you run
to the h line
and that if she had some time on the
clock to really look at it maybe she
should have
she could have found but instead she
went very instinctively
which we all do in time pressure and
hope that it was okay but that g takes
on f2 with check that was the whole
prayer that got answered just the fact
that
it was check on g on f2 and then a per
pet
amazing turnaround for karissa and she's
still in it we
get to watch the last round what's going
on
guys i thought the last round might just
be like okay
uh but if there's a game it is a game as
irena crashed
and karissa yep um half a point to buy
them so it's all about the
final round if irina wins she clinches
this title
let's take a look at their pairings but
we do know that irena plays white
against emily nguyen
emily is a very tough player so that
will be a good game no doubt
and then we also have carissa yet versus
talia cervantes he's
talia very up and down seems in time
scrambles he can sometimes slip up a
little bit
so karissa's definitely gonna go for it
here
and meanwhile dorsa is still in it if
irina
loses and um chris only draws he plays
against pathetic abrahamian
three-way tie for first coming up haha
yes oh wait
where's the wins irina loses and carissa
draws
don't put money on that quickly guys
it's a part like that
i cannot believe carissa won i cannot
believe carissa won
i really thought this was over but even
though my pick is
arena for this tournament i love it
that we get to watch round 11 i love it
too
i mean i love it i'm like yes i feel bad
for anna because she was
on our way to winning the first game of
the tournament but on the other hand
for the fans for the drama we want the
last round to be live
and it certainly is live we are going to
watch the exciting final round of the
u.s women's championship in just a few
minutes
don't go anywhere
[Music]
in this position queen to e1
on the board and now rook f2 wins
bishop f2 wins bishop d5 wins
everything wins now we could see a
champion
being crowned as she has so many good
moves this rook move
that's the one we all see right i mean
this threat is so
huge that's going to cost material
queenie won
absolutely the least tenacious move she
could have played
and black has secured a bishop on b3 and
a bishop on e3 with a rook about to come
into f2
we all know that's done
the realization has really set in you
can see that she's like oh my gosh
and even worse you know oftentimes uh
somebody you know shows me a game and
say why do i lose
why did i lose and i point to a piece
that they never ever
moved in the game and anna's looking at
that rook on a1
guess what she's getting up from the
board you know she's definitely a minute
and a half
she knows it's over her heart's broken
by the way rook f2 is one killer move
but bishop f2 with the sacrifice
on g3 is also absolutely crushing
so give us the line if you play bishop
f2 you got to move your queen somewhere
it doesn't matter where
bishop takes with check on g3 king takes
queen c7 we saw
the bishops alone do this march sending
the king up the board
you don't need a queen to do that too i
mean now your king has
nowhere to go king g4 bishop to e6 with
check
and you've got to go up board and guess
who's waiting is a
giant queen to deliver the death blow
king over and mate that's it
bishop f2 wins easily by force
done deal and she's got both moves
bishop f2
or rook f2 you see anna there completely
frustrated
and it's played the more spectacular
line bishop f2 queen d2 and now we're
waiting for bishop g3
to crown a champion with this kind of
move
yeah what a finish what a what a
gorgeous line that jen is going for
she absolutely sees it um you know
all these young players get readings
like this at this age
you know they've done their tactics well
i'm just kind of
thrown backwards because i'm i'm
remembering all of the interviews that
maurice was
was making at the start of the
tournament who has the advantage the
veterans
or the youngsters while the youngster
says oh
well we have the advantage we're there's
more of
us than they are of them that's why
we're what
marie says what about grand master
titles what about higher ratings
all that stuff doesn't matter well we
only do have one grand master in
the field irena crasher was not having a
good tournament but ana zakanski
was playing a grand master for most of
the event but
not this game this game she came with
some fantastic preparation
but always showing this resilience uh
this ability to play pretty quickly even
if she's caught unaware
her confidence no remember what i said
about going into somebody's kitchen
this is what happens when you go in
somebody's kitchen you decide you're
going to play against a line that's very
solid
and you say you know what i'm going to
prep against this and she's
done there it is bishop takes g3 check
you can't take with the king or queen c7
she has taken because she would have
lost her h pawn
and that would have been over as well
here comes queen c7 check
and this is resigns king going up the
board bishop e6 check
will land with a thud there it is bishop
six check chen
playing instantly a straight beat down
time for the handshake and there it is
congratulations
to jennifer you our 2019
u.s women's chess champion wow what a
feeling
what it looks like it looks like he is
very emotional it recalls the year that
the first year that nazi won right
he is just so excited waiting for that
smile i know
ninety percent nine out of
ten what a boss performance
by this young lady she might have called
herself luckily
other games but not now that was no luck
in that one
unstoppable smile
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 u.s women's championship here are
our standings after
10 rounds irena cross with seven and a
half points she's the front runner
karissa yiff though she has stayed in
the game after
an insane time scramble against anna
zatonski where
karissa came out ahead dursa derek
shawnee
will have to see irina lose to get in
the mix for first place but still
a tremendous performance for the lowest
rated player in the field
let's take a look at our final round
pairings well the two biggies of course
are carissa
verstalia and irina crash versus emily
nguyen irina could wrap this up
but emily very strong player she's
really coming to our own in this event
and that
she's played some tremendous games uh i
think just you know we didn't get a
chance to really look at it very much
um but she must have lost her last game
right
to um
yeah we barely looked at it
it is not that significant but by the
way
if you look at that that leaderboard
it's so funny how chess works but if you
look at that leaderboard again
you if if i take if we just take
dorsa and ana that leaderboard and
flip them take dorsa and put it where
anna is
and anna and put it where dorse is you'd
say oh it's a regular day at the us
women's championship
like everybody's score you have tatev
right up there
jennifer up there as well not having the
greatest tournament
any maybe you know having a bad event
but not
un unbelievable but that would be the
only
flip it just goes to show how the cream
rises how ratings matter
and in the end it's one and two for the
title basically
because i think doris's chances of
winning this are very slim
but again it's if you it's a pick them
up the numbers one and number two in the
tournament
and see who's going to win and right now
of course you renamed the driver's seat
and they are off for this championship
round
and by the way this is the type of
situation that we as commentators simply
love live for i want to say i mean
everything to play for 25 000 u.s
women's championship title up for grabs
the crowning of a champion
this is as good as it gets guys and
we're seeing
in the game of arena a exchange slot
maybe not to everybody's taste but she's
saying
look uh i want to secure a great
performance i mean i don't want to
play too risky and she's traded and
played bishop b5
a little bit offbeat system and emily is
the first to think
i would play for the win if i had white
but again
not when you play for a win doesn't mean
that you have to play risky chess
right one person who's definitely
playing for our win you guys it's
karissa yip and you're gonna like this
opening guys
okay a sicilian one of our favorite
openings to call is
it always gets wild and carissa as we've
seen
um also loves to play creative
sacrifices in this
there was that game from the u.s junior
girls that was totally insane with the
sacrifice on
e5 and a chase all across the board
um this one i feel like is a great great
outcome for
the uh the runner-up and the standings
right now i agree and may i just i just
want to throw this and finish my point
playing for a draw as far as
as far as our leader is concerned irina
is dangerous because if she lets carissa
tie her
she could lose the title that way she's
in control of her own destiny so if she
draws
and carissa does what she's supposed to
do in this game and be the lower rated
player you're playing a tie break
and why do you want to do that she
catches you at the end and she feels
like all the world is hers
because she needed to win two games she
magically won this last game
wins this one she's like oh bring it i'm
after you
yeah and it's not clear to me that irena
has a big edge on
um carissa as the time controls get
faster i mean even in classical chess
they're neck and neck but i think as
they get faster actually karissa could
have a small edge you know being
um that irena is not you know not as
famous for her blitz skills is for her
classical skills so
um i think she's gonna gonna play um
it might seem like she's playing the
exchange slab and once a draw but i
don't think irena has draw on the menu i
think she's just playing
um with a little less risk but not to
make a quick draw
that's why i was that's what i meant she
needs to play keep the game going and
look at this last move
that carissa just played do you think
she's playing for a win
in this game by the way between carissa
and talia we're seeing an interesting
echo
of the game that carissa played
with arena because of the move
g7 g5 right here and right
now i tend to think of the move g2 g4
as premature uh you're going to need to
play
castles no matter what you're going to
do you're going to play castles
so play castles and play a move that you
absolutely going to have to play
before expanding on the king side with
g4
i'm just thinking that g7 g5 is
the proper move for talia to play
and i'm sure we're still in theory too
by the way not like
g4 is a terrible move or something like
that it's just that
i really really want players to be
exacting their openings and their
defensive
opening moves so after g5
uh you'd almost say hey i like the fact
you played g5 let me play g3 and protect
my pawn uh the whole
idea behind g5 as irina herself
mentioned
is to earn the e5 square for the knight
and here we see
a shining example of that and talia
did not play g5 she went for
b5 and then karissa answering maurice's
question again
doesn't even take a break the castle
just let's go
let's go gotta love it
four pawns of breasts on the fa
or the from the east or the h file no
more g five
i think you were gonna say from baylank
from
east to west uh again
i'm not really a big fan of this move i
just want to say
uh to the audience if you thought
that e 4 e5 was a winning move
and uh um carissa missed it as you're
attacking the knight and the rook i'll
turn that tables uh completely
with the move bishop b7 attacking the
queen and
in turn skewering europe so e5 is not on
tap
the problem i'm having with h4 now is a
completely different
idea a completely different idea and
that is h5
uh by talia the idea here is if you
attack the knight the knight takes up a
roost
because it's on a protected square on g4
and it makes it really hard for white
to pursue her attack aggressively whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yeah
the sicilian the sicilian player i mean
it says g6
and uh what are we discussing here
we're discussing a crazy a crazy mixed
up mess is what we're discussing right
here
those cameras because i take on f7 and i
got e6 hanging
uh we we got this is this is party time
this position's nuts g4 can come on to
fire e5
can happen at some point as well i don't
know it still
seems very sharp and don't forget f5
could happen at some point also i mean
this is
this is chaos still this is just
straight
straight chaos on the chessboard it
ain't easy
here i i would recommend the move h5
whether it's
as you say chaos or whatever uh the
problem is
if you don't play h5 if you play i don't
care
move like rook b8 just picking a move
maybe you prefer bishop b7
you simply don't have a good answer to
g5 no
you're right it's just really really bad
because if you move i'm playing g6
and under a much much much better
uh circumstance the the knight doesn't
have a
stable staple square sorry by the way
how do you play h5 g5 knight g4 if i
don't play g6 i play bishop h3
another tempo move oh
that's wonderful that that one i let you
have
like take take my pawn please kind of
thing
um let's imagine i play g6 and let's
imagine for example you'd capture right
so you're kind of like thinking to
yourself oh boy i've got
these ideas but let's see how do i do it
uh myself i'm gonna i'm gonna change
directions on you maurice i'm gonna go
knight to b6 with the idea of e5
gaining a tempo on your queen and
hitting the knight and i'm thinking of
knight c4 so in other words i sacrifice
a pawn
just to slow down the attack you know
one two moves on the king side
uh and you win a pawn but you lose the
initiative
you know me i'm not trying to lose any
initiative
i want to i want to play h5 and i'm
thinking of
the sacrifice of knight f5
but you do have uh yeah okay whatever
it's not my piece i'm sacrificing no
it's not that's a beautiful part about
coventry is you could say ah
i'll take that one back uh but that's
the idea i mean that's the concept there
yeah if you don't know this position
you're
this is guesswork on the part of talia
and we can see she doesn't know the
position
she's not sure exactly how to deal with
the threats your experience has
told you i've seen gary kasparov himself
do this idea of h5 exactly
you know you've seen it we've seen this
before talia on the other hand
to defend this and not know what's
coming at her
against a powerful player like karissa
this is going to be a big challenge
you don't want to defend a sicilian if
you don't have specific techniques
coming out your pocket
just move after move after move to save
yourself and this a3 move that she got
in the opening
making b4 not a move to disturb
the equanimity of the dino c3 this is
concrete world we're living in right now
black
better play the right things but she's
about to get blown off the board
i think so maurice this is not something
i mean this is just so easy to play for
white black
has to be prepared um for these uh
crushing ideas that carissa has up her
sleeve
oh big opportunity by the way and um
the big move is knight c5 is if you're
not gonna play h5 the alternative is
knight c5 by the way the idea here
is that g5 you're hoping that as you
know
into this uh how do you say this
chaotic explosive position you
you have time for bishop b7 and
skewering the rook so this is the stuff
that talia is trying to calculate
with very little time in the clock a
rapid game sorry
[Music]
jen you wanted to take us somewhere
where would you like me to go
well let's i mean i'm fixated on this
game but let's take a quick look at
dorsa versus tatev as
uh that game is that was a french
defense yes
and please go to irina's game after this
when you're done because
irina did get exactly what she wanted in
the opening
that's arena that's like that's
precisely the kind of woman she wants
but here
dorsa has the white pieces against tatev
uh yes and uh i have no idea
you know every french defense player
knows that the light square bishop is
the problem piece
and man uh there are problem pieces and
then a really problem bishop
a bishop on c8 looks i don't know what
c7 c6 is if that's theory you know slap
me silly
i don't like that move at all i'm much
more familiar
with ideas of a6 and b5 and bishop b7
in these positions i just don't know
what c6
does to enhance the bishop we're jumping
to the game between arena
and emily because that when we left it
it was this
slaw of defense exchange slav i'm sorry
with bishop f5 and
okay irina's got very good very nice
very safe castles and she's got
on her agenda queen a4 and rook c1
and emily could be in real real trouble
like that you get about 95. did you
mention that one too
nope it didn't mean you know it's really
nice when you're playing all those moves
and you don't mention another nice
little move 95
that's yeah no one none of us wants to
be in this position
none of us at this on this commentary
team
wants this position is black like uh-uh
know-how no way
we're not defending it well exactly so
if i'm in
black shoot okay emily made a move that
i like i think that that's kind of one
of those moves
that has a dual purpose you definitely
know that c6 is your
target pawn and you're you're planning
to meet queen a4 with queen b5 so it has
a dual purpose type of moves
i was thinking since white's play is so
straightforward this rook on
f1 is definitely definitely going to see
one
you as black you might want to thrown in
this move first
to get a situation where who knows maybe
the bishop has some ideas of b5 she
didn't do that
she went queen b6 and now i'm really
worried
how will emily handle queen b3
again uh i'm just playing for the very
straight
what you just said maurice uh 95
and rook on fc1 and i'm saying uh
give me that putty cat yeah that looks
like food
you know i was i was i was doing
i was calling or streaming that's what i
was looking for i was streaming on
twitch the second time i've ever done it
a few days ago
okay and i was streaming on twitch and i
said
it was later in the day and i said
that looks like food it's a some
situation
and the more i spoke i started using
references like eat
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna snack on
that and i started saying wait a second
you know angry and then i realized that
i was hungry so i said let me not just
keep talking
about food chess and food references but
then i couldn't stop
just the whole time i just kept making
food references eat this
a bunch on that but the whole time in
the show
people were laughing at me as that kept
happening but
you know in chess it looks like food
yeah we're eating it that's it
munching on a free pod let me get that
snack
absolutely guys i mean when they do um
experiments you know to see what happens
to a body when you
um have like just a little bit less
calories than normal
um people just have all these fantasies
and dreams of cake and
ice cream it's pretty funny
yeah but i think we even see it they see
it everywhere
they they read the word quickly more
quickly it's it's crazy
um so anyway in this position we like
irena's game but
i she didn't play queen b3 actually she
just played knight to b3
so clearly she wants to occupy c5
um with a piece and and not rush on
trade in queens okay
i i would have expected queen v3 from
her too guys so this does surprise me a
little bit
i think she's keeping a little bit more
in the position with her queen on
say just in case the end game is not
winning enough
let me keep the queens on i do agree
though queen b3 looked superb
but that said she's not in any danger
looks like
if she wins she wins the whole thing but
somebody who has to win
is carissa and we did see the maneuver
that we talked about with h5 yes g5
yeah and g6 she's thinking she's saying
one thing on her mind and it's
seek and destroy that's it she's not
playing any quiet moves
she's playing the most aggressive move
in the position every time she can play
it
uh a little surprised by talia's
decision
knight takes f2 here one of the nice
things about this
knight is actually it really kind of
gummies up white's attack
like it's very clear that this bishop is
going to go to h3 it's going to target
e6 the rook is going to go to g1
half open g file let's go when you trade
off
this knight you you're left in a
position where
it's it's going to be awfully hard
for talia to plug up the
file the g-file as well as the diagonal
on h3 that bond on e6 is really weak in
fact it's so weak
the only thing the only protection it
has is the king
knight f6 just got played so she's
trying to answer both your questions
bishop guarding e6 and the knight being
able to go
to the g4 square just for square
right i mean i know this in f5 coming e5
coming no
this is too strong for charissa guys too
strong
chris is in heaven right now oh yeah oh
yeah i would love it as well
she's got 10 minutes too she's up 10
minutes with eight now she's up eight
minutes
on the clock her position is beautiful
it's easy to play for hawaii
um i i think this just couldn't have
gone better for carissa
now agreed yeah he has margin of error
here
i think that's the problem usually in
the sicilian you you make like one screw
up and you lose here it feels like
carissa could you choose like a number
of cats and
and still black is just in big trouble
yeah like and just as a comparison for
example if
uh italia had left these
uh knight on the board you can see that
from
talia's point of view uh she's
ready to play rook f8 and king g8
you know the kind of castling by hand
sequence
and the knight on g4 helps stop
this bishop attack uh trading conversely
just kind of opened up the floodgates
and i think yeah she did play bishop h3
made it very easy a big big big
advantage to carissa i agree with you
wholeheartedly jen
guys we saw carissa go for it with g4 in
this game we've seen the theme happen
quite often the sicilian czech who's
played g4 in her game when we thought
she was going to say
doris slightly and it's irina
irina when we thought she was after the
c6 pawn
and would just play a quiet life and go
for that
she decided okay i'm i'm attacking the
pawn
all right let me go after it you defend
it you expect some solid move to build
up on the pawn natural play she said
uh-uh g4 on the other side of the board
what an aggressive stance to take
what's she after here i know that black
was threatening c5 by the way
black is looking to play c5 but g4 i
think we just play
followed up with h4 and then you're
forced to play h6 or h5 to save your
bishop and
um our position is fantastic if we just
take on g6 and your pawns are just
terrible h6 oh you play h5 instead
okay knight g6 pawn g6 and um g5
funny that h5 was a recipe for both g4
moves
but yeah this the the badness of the
black pawns
is really really something i like that
yeah emily decided to play bishop before
by the way
so um she's thinking i guess that you'd
like to induce the move f3 before she
plays
um bishop g6 but wait wait wait wait
wait you just occupied a square
what's g5 here g5 you have to play 98
right
in the main position sorry not not this
position yet on bishop e4 i just could
we refute
g5 on the first move after bishop to e4
uh g5 on the first here
she played bishop e4 oh that's what i'm
saying
oh sorry okay i i i got the wrong
position i was thinking
that she played bishop g6 no knight e8
only move box yeah
all right now i could i get c5 but maybe
that's just
i'm playing two positionally right now
oh wait i have queen h5
also will you play bishop g6
yeah maybe i didn't get queen h5 knight
d6 defending the pawn on f7
well i can always get you to play this
this oh i guess you could put the bishop
on f5 also
no this is not quite right this is too
solid open
opening up squares we need to be more
aggressive now that we said a we're
going to have to say b
and f3 and go for this position and it
has occurred
f3 bishop back to g6 and now
we're all thumping this the board for h4
and he's not so much for playing solid
chess guys
she's going for it well this just looks
great i mean the thing is even after
taking on g6 and g5 what's so unsolid
about it white just has a
nice um position to play against right i
mean it's like a normal-ish
position except you have that g6
weakness that you normally wouldn't have
right like if i play queen d3 or
something or queen c2
and you're forced to play king h7 or
king f7
seems just like an extra headache that
you usually don't have to deal with
she played h6 instead uh-huh
that's not so good uh i'm not convinced
that this position would have been that
terrible for black uh sorry how did we
get that we
that moment where we just left i think
it was this moment
i'm not convinced that this is really
that terrible i mean
i don't like black structure that is
true but
what's the bad piece this knight's okay
this bishop's okay king's okay queen's
okay i'm
threatening maybe on a good day to play
c5
if i get in c5 i
kings a little bit exposed over here
maybe h4
g5 or in the same color as the bishop
i'm just saying it's not that bad
but h6 that says to me
[Music]
now arena has a
as a hook that she could potentially
just
blast open the king side and that could
really work
in her favor very very well um not a big
fan of this move
h6 i see what you think she's
i think she was in trouble in any event
but
this one you're right that g5 hook
like for example suppose i just blunder
i play bad move rook f2
just saying your turn right i'm not
necessarily
taking on g6 and playing rook c2
eyeballing the pawn
but i just want you to play this move
bishop h7 right which
looks reasonable now you're not
uh falling for knight takes g6 now i
play rook g2
and i say okay your turn again
and you start to understand well
uh g5 is going to really force
open the king side i'm going to go g5
gh6 and yes
and if you play c5 this is one of the
really bad
news situations for example
i'll go like this you can't take because
of knight
d7 i've got g6 also to open things up
there's a vision check into mezzo there
oh
sorry sorry sorry i i have to do it in
another way i apologize you take first
word
yeah i have to do it like that but okay
these are things that i'm saying why
black had to play h5 h6 just gives white
more flexibility and arena
she has a total driver's seat total
driver's seat
she hasn't moved yet quickly yeah she
well kind of in the mix
right because she took on g6
and we're hearing they're being told
what nerd okay
alert let's take a look wonder alert
yes we're being told that carissa did
not play
the right move she played rook
g1 just a moment just a moment hold on
there's some
tactical issues based on e5 right
right i think that's the problem this
this bishop is hanging suddenly
so if we take we could maybe take
this oh oh oh oh and this guy is hanging
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa e5
that's right e5 great move uh oh
okay e5 knight f5 that's not what i
wanted at all
oh definitely not funny not a chance is
what i wanted but yeah but
you're not losing right totally get it
or take on e5
and and then knight f5 right
oh no that would well no if you attack
on f
if you take on
on e5 you're
you're are you blundering a bishop well
just a second
no this is weird i don't know
maybe jen but i could maybe recapture
five right away it was probably
um better because here it will here if i
play to five you can take and then
play bishop c5 check and then knight e3
there's bishop h3
so this would lose right agreed
no no that's terrible right away at
least keeps
the diagonal from opening up on us
well for black from black's point of
view
a little bit of heart palpitation relief
that i get to trade queens and i don't
know i snabble upon i agree my
my my my rook is a little goofy but
just get she missed it she missed it she
played knight g4
what of
of dodge there with uh okay
remember to take take and then play e5
but there's a checkpoint well no
remember i was saying that it's
it's a very common theme in
uh this line of the night or that you
you just give a pawn you just give up a
pawn and say
okay so uh don't don't think that oh
black has to play ultra aggressively
rook h4 or queen h5 or something like
that but they just play
upon down and they just say it's okay
you know
just it's it's it's a great bishop
i don't know that's what they do
i hear you but not necessarily in this
position that we're staring at
oh no we were looking at e5 i think she
missed e5
oh e5 is what you were saying okay this
position
i'm sure she i'm sure she missed e5 e5
was better but
knight g5 g4 is not terrible it's not
a bad move e5 was better
all right now the decision and she did
not
take on g4 she castled
stacking the bomb on each force
she's playing the again the most
aggressive move i think she's literally
in her brain
it's play the most aggressive move you
could play
on every single move because she didn't
even
bother to look at rook takes g4 she just
said whatever i'm not playing
like that i'm going to castle i'm going
to attack i'm going to attack and i'm
going to type g6 i'm just going to keep
attacking
until something happens it just it's a
formula for this game
even giving up this h pawn maybe she
wasn't afraid of queen h5
maybe carissa i mean
you like grabbing ponds i'm sure carissa
had a very
concrete reason why she didn't take but
okay she did castle and she is offering
a palm so what's her idea
what what's white's follow-up to rook
takes h4
f5 what else can you play e
e5 is possible too but i'm not sure
which one
f5 e5 f5 e5
oh sorry my bad my my knight's hanging
all right so e5
so e5
okay now my king
i'm not a big fan i agree i'm not a big
fan but
let's put my king a little bit
out of harm's way hold on hold on hold
on i want to play knight e4
just for freebie before i took on e5 i
want to know where your
queen's gonna go first oh and i'll have
a knight g5 checked
okay now we're talking
your rook is hanging on h4
knight e5 check like g5 knight g5 to
block your defense
and then take back on g5 with the
discover check so this is going to be a
whole rook
uh knight check check and
queen takes h4
[Music]
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot so
i have to do something else i'm not a
big fan if i go d5
then f5 looks pretty good okay
has played rook h4 and now
now it's the money moment right here
guys
uh carissa like you said marie she's fun
playing
ultra aggressive like crazy
the most aggressive move you can e5 is
coming i'm betting money on e5
i like it what's your other movie anyway
dying to do it yeah what other move is
there anyway because f5 was a blunder
so e5 and i'm just let's find another
move even
let's find an alternative yeah well king
b1
the whole max just relax
queens
she's playing e5 and go thump
this is this is going to be the cave
woman
playing move okay ooh i'm not sure jen's
gonna like that cable
well when you say when you say caveman
she usually edits and says cave
woman sorry person yes i'm okay with
this he's going for it guys
so after bishop b7 i don't know a better
move i don't
know what else i'm playing if i have to
play a five
she's gonna play a five and and just
go for it so what's the big idea that's
nice
the big idea we're taking on e7 and
playing queen f7
e6 and playing queen f7 check if you're
a knight oh and now knight f5 comes in
check knight f5
e5 on the board and that i mean this she
played it
she played it she's going for it
absolutely and this looks crushing in
this position
in front of us the b7 is the only move
right now
sorry she played g bishop bishop b7 says
var
she played d5 instead and
how can she played it instantly but
existed
how could you possibly resist playing
she wants to stop knight e4
and not move her bishop away so f5 takes
maurice
i know i don't even know that's i don't
even know the next goal oh
i just couldn't be just playing the move
okay let me look
i don't care it's the most aggressive
move you play it okay now what do we
need to do against this gunfighter
my queen is actually pinned you know
they're playing for the women's
championship
no we're commentators we can sack
anytime we want
uh okay this i don't have a natural
follow-up e6 doesn't get the job done
b4 doesn't get the job done
hmm all right well um var is filling us
in with the correct move he said that
um h1 is the strongest move
um winning what
i mean yes and what she's not playing
rick h1
that's deep and and i i'd be really
impressed that rook h1 lands on the
board
that that's that's a high class
move that says that the position is
stable
you know as you look at it you can argue
the position is stable
i don't need to do anything now because
it's stable
and so i can trade off all the right
defensive pieces and go get you
but this takes time and patience we've
sacked a pawn but you've got lots of
weaknesses
so it's not like we've sat the piece and
we need to like immediately show some
brilliant lie
no you're right you're absolutely right
she's instead played queen g2
now now we're talking f5
and she wants to play f5 that makes
sense to me that's
that's a beautiful move that's a
beautiful move
love that move you're right because
before f5
um we we couldn't take back with the
knight because queen f2 and now also d5
oh this is nice that's quality looking
move to me
in the attack not not leave the rook on
h1 alone
on h4 alone yes maybe the computer says
it's winning but
leave it alone and play like g8
just play king g8 and just your turn i'm
not sure i understand the move queen g2
help me out here guys
okay what do you want to play you want
to play king g8 you say yeah
just get out of dodge the king is
dangerous
king king is getting too dangerous okay
i'll take that
that helps keep forgetting how greedy
you are
one 65 rook a7 so i get out of
any trickeries and i finally developed
my rook
yes but your bit can your queen your
queen can't hold your bishop so
wait no but i don't get that oh knight
c6
hello interesting knight c6
yeah okay check
and he's got a little czech ski that's a
bit annoying okay
my king okay but
hold on time out time here i'm defending
with
everybody everybody is defending
my king wow hey um we should we should
this this as this variation explodes
let's take a quick look at the irena
game yes
if arena wins let's remind everybody if
arena wins
that's it that's it that's the women's
champion right there
and when we left it she took on g6 and
played queen
c2 gift meet upon on g6
king f7 not ideal for emily to bring her
king to f7
king h2 wow that's a move
a5 rook g1
wow talk okay things have really heated
up here guys i don't know
uh my feeling is that the king was not
good on
h2 that i had expected rook f2 and rook
g2
but this still looks better for
uh arena
it's it's wild it's wild
completely okay let's go
let's just go bishop g3 and imagine what
happens next
i'm not sure again i don't like the
setup of the pieces for white king on
h2 rook on g1 i'd like to flip them in
fact
but imagine bishop g3
i don't think why why didn't you take on
why didn't you take on uh
on g5 again well i was afraid of rook
check and i was afraid of knight takes g
for so it's afraid of something like
this
i've got a threat of rook h2 i've got a
threat of bishop g fun
[Music]
but your king is open too yeah it's not
all oh yeah oh yeah
so it takes back on g4
you can check and probably she did take
on g5 by the way
and i immediately played rook hack
so this is it this is the tournament
right here
yeah if arena doesn't believe her if
emily
is if knight takes g4 uh
fails uh let's put it that way if knight
takes g4 fails
then arena's just cruising she's got an
extra pawn she'll play bishop takes f6
she'll put a knight on c5
she'll have extra pawn and great
positional
compensation on her side of the table as
well so it's right here if knight takes
g4
fails and we think it does right
because of this there's a check yeah
and we don't f6 allows g5 so
bishop m6 allows g5 just a sec
though uh right here because
we've got crazy moves queen c7
threatening rook h2 we've got
moves like rook h5
just there's bart says
the t4 does not work fg4 bishop g5
rook cf1 and queen g6
yeah we've got that part but you know
we're watching about bishop
we're pretty sure that bishop queen you
know that would
that would win the game um but
yesterday's move of
rook h5c7 all these moves do come
with a little intrigue yeah
i i suspect that var is right that this
is really really really good for
arena you just you know when when the
title is you know the trophy
is you know you can feel your fingers
just kind of holding the trophy of
breasts you're kind of like okay let's
make sure
that i am winning indeed by the way do
you think she's going to
play bishop f6 when that check happens i
mean
that's that requires really some
gumption yeah
that position but if i but we need to
switch here
because carissa did yes the move g6
didn't even allow for the f5 argument
in that game talia stopped it completely
and forced carissa to play rook h1 which
was a good move to be which was a good
move
and she has nothing else to do so she
made her find the good move and then she
was able to win the g-pawn
so material is equal her knight under
attack she could
i was going to say drop it back knight
to where we want to go knight f3
and we're playing g5 and we're
threatening we're and we're running
knight d5 i was thinking rook d5 too but
okay we can just play the prosaic knight
d5 as
that pawn on e6 is pinned i mean
depending on what happens rook d5 might
work too and she did play knight f3
oh the threats are enormous here 94 too
94 is also on the board
mm-hmm it's a threat yes
everything that exposed king is the
difference the bishops are saying
nothing and the knights are
dancing and don't let the c3 knight in
the game it's bad enough you're gonna
let
the knight go to g5
it's lights out over there uh yeah the
whole king side just
open highways to black's king i think
she had to play that king g8 idea and
g7 g6 was just way too slow
way too slow by tell ya this
is looking very much like a victory
carissa at 11
37 on the clock let's check it down to
lesser three minutes
looks better we haven't seen much of her
game
uh we didn't lie i didn't like her i
didn't like contests opening
one one bit um
but by the way if if carissa wins dorsa
is also mathematically eliminated so
eliminated we recognize that this game
is just for uh
bookings maybe fourth third or fourth
yeah it could be a great result
it'll be a great result but it's not
going to get her
the title as irina looks great and and
carissa for sure look also looks great
yeah and carissa will um surpass her
regardless if she wins this now todd
said if she can somehow turn this around
and win
will actually um bring herself to her
towards derek johnny's score
and sharon some of those bigger prizes
at the top of the table so
lots of money at stake in this game but
no title
i'm just looking at some uh variation
where he sack
a whole rook here for dorsa with the
move
g3 trying to make it work you take the
rook
uh does tatav and then i've got the
bishop coming to b5 with a
nasty discover check but then the
question always is
well how nasty is it what do guys think
of this uh
rook sacrifice intriguing or
too much talent
you can't play queen f3 by the way
because that does
walk into a very nasty discovered check
and if i play queen e4 then i got
rook e1 that's that's certainly a
monstrous move
pretty interesting say the least okay
we'll see if
but you're right if uh if dorsa wins
it's it's a wonderful wonderful
tournament
but guess what it's not going to get her
the trophy
if irina wins or if
we need it we have the moment we have
the moment with the arena
irina has the moment that we're talking
about
she this is it play
queen g6 oh she didn't play that's what
i said do you think she's gonna play
bishop f6
that's exactly what i asked because g5
you you're gambling
that everything works out instead she's
allowed queen
to be able to go to g6 in this position
but let's go to karissa's game
as she looks like she is going to
potentially surpass
irina uh yeah she's just like rook h1
and um that forced rook g8 which is a
minute left on talia's clock
but rook h7 check um could be played
anyway and then after rook g7 how do you
keep
how do you uh keep this
show going knight g5 check
um i would start with knight g5
myself but okay either way but knight g5
check looks winning to me
you're playing you have queen h3 no yeah
uh
so she has to move the rook back first
and then
then play queen age three all the time
in the world
yes rook h2 rick h2 no rook h2 bishop e3
check
that's fine that's just one that might
move the king and then say deal okay so
we're looking at
rook here bishop check move the king and
then we're saying okay deal with the
threat of queen h3
and queen h8 mate and by the way the
bishops hanging
yep so we think rook h ii
beautiful retreating move she's played
rick h1
one it doesn't it doesn't matter as far
as she's concerned find a move
similarly no time
no time on her clock she's under a
minute
to carissa's 10 and the position's just
lost
so carissa is going to be for a moment
at least
in the lead in first place it looks that
way
three coming oh boy she dodged the
bullet for one moment bishop c6 played
not sure what that does bishop where
bishop c6
oh okay that seems to do nothing at all
because e6 is now hanging as well so
that's going to make it even worse after
queen h3 you can't even run with king f8
because there's also a 96 check in the
position
agreed yeah absolutely agreed
that's a fork and and
yeah and she's done it she's playing
between eight
three it's time to resign exactly
big win by carissa after getting
a second life with the last game
thank you very much anna zadowski gave
her this chance she will
overtake irina for a moment irina still
has to win that game guys
let's go and see if she can we know this
is over wait a second let's just wait
let's not leave yet leave that position
on the board you have on the right
is she going to flag here because she's
only got 10 seconds yeah she's got 10
seconds so let's
let's leave this yeah so you can go over
to the other game while we take a look
at this one on the left because
this one is just resignation king over
but we know knight e6 is but we're look
at this position
knight takes irena's position is also
looking pretty crazy but this one looks
like you're going to just
mop up doesn't check winner win a whole
rook
she hits the rook instead there's queen
c8 oh it is queen c8 also
bye bye that's it nothing left to do
and that's the game carissa in the first
at the moment big four eight points and
we see a little smile for carissa
uh it looks like it's unlikely to be
enough to win her first u.s women's
championship because irena's position is
dominant but yes maurice she still has
to win the game
and she's just played this fantastic
move did arena crush she played the move
rook h1 which i think is
just uh you know exquisitely
uh well-timed um
she she's threatening to take the rook
and take the bishop
and then follow it up with queen g7 and
so queen b5
was played uh with the idea of settling
scores here
with a queen uh check so all arena has
got to do
is really just neutralize that threat
probably a move like king f3
stopping the queen from coming in while
renewing
everything rook h8 and pawn takes g5
renewing all the threats and arena
should
be winning with king f3
is there another also i suspect there
must be other
winning moves here as well she's got
three minutes left on the clock
will she find the pathway to her eighth
u.s women's championship title
on the line right now which i thought i
thought eight would be enough to win
today guys or at least to get a play off
but no irena crush trying to win both
games
to keep that happening lead against them
by the way dominant fashion
her last three wins will be remarkable
the way she won three in a row to close
this out
let's see if you can do it and a half
minutes emily
emily's fighting hard playing queen b5
her only
chance here is something like rook h8
would allow the queen to just start
checking and no no no not once
acceptable
unacceptable she needs to play the the
move i don't know guys
starting to wonder i think she sees it
though she's calm
but two it's gonna be two minutes left
i'll get stressed if she goes under a
minute i'm
i'm stressed now
two minutes two minutes to emily's four
and a half
minutes and she didn't
a little bit there i noticed uh on this
move but i don't know that it's
that significant is there brook takes
and takes
also threatens queen g7 so white is
threatening a very big move
i can't find a single move for black so
white's threat is that
for example i've just put a bad move on
the position if
a4 you trade first on h8 you take
you take you take on f6 with a check
and you pick up the rook so you're
completely
winning materially and at the moment
after the move king of three the problem
that black is facing is
frankly the bishop is trapped if the
bishop
captures the pawn the knight captures
now you're covering e2 with the knight
so your king can happily move away and
queen e6 is on tap
and it's a disaster for emily so
this is the problem that black is facing
is the bishop is simply trapped and rook
h8 is a huge threat
the rook h8 threat provoked rook
takes h well look at this
and rook h1 was followed by rook to
f8 that's a resourceful move you just
you don't want to have these kind of
annoying little plays still in the
position
even if you're winning just the mere
fact that she had another move
like she's still moving why is she still
moving sit still please
king g3 played now there's a
there's a queen ba check playable or
queen e2
okay so once again we're threatening
just to take questions
i prefer we need to actually like more
yes
okay well the bishop is dead the bishop
is going to go
well now we take the bishop with check
though that's the problem right
yikes hold on give rook takes
rook takes queen takes check rook f7
rook f7 no queen g5
right makes sense no rook five
right what do you mean no queen g5 no
queen g5 wins right
well i'm threatening rook f3 queen f2 uh
why are you okay yeah well i
i was like i want to walk a plank
okay so that that's actually kind of
funny because if you go king d6 i go
check
right oh yeah yeah i don't want that
time yeah
night shack king c7 king c7
night shack i'm walking all right
you can't keep there i can't go
oh my goodness this is a knight d7 d8
check
that's right i just say that stopped
everything
unbelievable and the queen will land on
d8 otherwise correct
okay that is going under two minutes
also it looks like
oh okay this is the this is it but
g3 on the she has the board because
queen b8 king g2
and it's finished so you must play you
must play for this movie but
i how about queen e8 takes
takes with a pawn so if you take with
the pawn
now you're threatening queen takes e3
check
and if you go rook talk about
running the plank
uh king d6 and you still got
oh she took with the rules she took with
the rook you're right there's still work
to do
it would have been weird to do but she
keeps
karina said thank you very much
wow where's your king gonna go because
king d6
mating uh very at night coming into the
park
seven eighty-five c5 check it plays
itself
it's a beautiful force no that would
have been queendia yeah no no no
this is it's clear and that's very clear
amazing the problem is the king doesn't
have a good
escape she's played it knight c5 check
king c7
emily plays but now irina
title is queen e5 check and the king's
gonna run out of places to go
if you go to b6 we have queen b8 hello
and if you go
back um we can invade as well
exactly and this is it
i mean she didn't play it she played
queen e5 check she must see uh
maybe clearer wayne she's done it and
look at her she was so happy
she made it and she cheered in that
moment
nice to meet you to win the championship
congratulations
irina she has got her eighth
championship after
four years of frustration she finally
did it in the fifth
and that is gonna go on our instant
replay we're gonna see if i have one
first place 25 000 and she becomes our
eight-time u.s women's champion
our 2020 champ as
let's see it there it is oh that's
jordan look at that
that is joy she deserved it give that
here a little spin
meanwhile i think we still have one more
game going on guys dorset derek shawnee
uh played a very visual move against
um tata barbara homie on a move 21
that queen on e4 got trapped oh
it did sacrifice the rook she did go for
it guys g3
takes bishop b5 and look at this
and she trapped the rook oh marvelous uh
dorsa has been playing inspire chess
i mean she will come up short as far
as the title is concerned but
big applause for dorsa she's really put
together some
very very nice games and it looks like
she's winning this one too
bishop d7 last move
yeah i mean materially there are those
um those two rooks but
the king on e7 dropping the e6 pawn
queen takes e6 by the way this bishop
might end up getting the the bishop
might end up getting trapped as well
queen takes e6 who could possibly resist
taking the pawn with check not me
i wouldn't resist i would also take a
second pawn with check because that
opens up
the square e5 for my knight and d6 is
going to threaten a queen g6
i'm queen g8 rather and there it is
right
c6 27 seconds left for dorsa
as tatev now um lovely
epaulette mate yes i love that pretty
one
yeah so it look it's looking
all roses for dorsa here
i mean our leaders came in and they
performed today guys this was a
championship
uh round and well championship day what
can i say
and you know carissa wins both of her
games
uh irina wins both of her games in dorsa
look at what she's doing now got one and
a half out of two today
that's right well not yet she still has
to win this
right exactly which she will probably
she does have 15 seconds left so
queen takes f6 like i say you know i'm
i'm a palm grupper
the more pawns the better that's the
motto
yeah it's played king b7
you can run but look at all those pawns
take another one
she did uh dorsa you're winning my art
look at this
uh queen takes f5 rook
um e7 on the board right queen d5
check okay it's time to bring our knight
back
or maybe actually maybe knight d6 is not
the most
necessary move yes she did it 96 check
i was wondering maybe she could have
played queen c5 check
and there it is as um doris so we'll get
the bronze medal in this event
third place it looks like for dorissa
second place of course for carissa yet
and we know we have a champion irina
cross
look at what you have to put up with all
she's trying to do is play a nice
methodical attacking game
and the house cat comes in and says my
turn
pay attention to me okay okay okay
you go away you go away fishing let's
see we still have jen you
um playing against anna zatonski
well as we do wait for all the games to
finish as
no doubt we're going to get a chance to
interview our champ quite soon
and unfortunately for both these
competitors jennifer you our defending
women's champion
did not have a good event and for anna
she's had a disastrous event there's
just
there's nobody on this one unless a
horrible blunder
she will not win a single game in this
event which
by the way annie annie wang just lost to
sabine foyser so sabine
executed a checkmate on the board here
so
well done sabina yeah
the two amazing juniors the precocious
ones from
the last two years annie and jennifer
had really poor results
true yeah
he felt like after she started losing
the wheels kind of came off
unfortunately
it was that day two that will go down
it's just like
a full disaster and he came into day two
as we know with a
a clear lead two and a half from three
could have been three from three and
then annie just had a disaster
three consecutive losses and she was out
of the tournament
like that
but wow that joy and arena you know such
frustration year after year after year
and to deliver the maximum results
when it counted with two of with three
of her best games look at that
extreme joy you live for moments like
that
she totally deserved it three wins in a
row when she needed it
and indeed she is once again the
champion
and we can start the the countdown guys
she's got eight
the ladies got eight eight's not enough
she's gotta get to nine
she's gotta get to nine to tie giselle
aggressor but she has
years ahead to pick up that title that's
right guys
talk talk about how difficult this
eighth was
though i mean she was on a drought four
four she came up empty the last four
years
and these and her rivals are getting
younger and stronger yes it's not going
to get any easier
absolutely not
and let's take a look at the end of
irena's game on beaches as she
chased emily's king always all the way
across the board
as we look at it try to run and that's
the problem though
we've been we were talking about that c5
square all game but we thought it was
mostly a positional square
it ended up being the mating square
emily trying to
create some counter play with queenie
too don't blame her
but look at this geometry the dark
squares
king d7 once the knight joins the party
it's too many guests and it's queen
five check king me marvelous move and
this got it done it's made into a rookie
seven queen v7 would be checkmate
and that is what elicited that yelp of
joy
i mean her audio wasn't on but i i can
assume there was a sound that
accompanied this
this not just one fist but two
yeah i think there was a lot of relief
in that too
it was certainly a lot of glee and joy
but also that
at last indeed brilliant brilliant
moment
you don't see that with chess a lot
players responding with that
kind of absolute exuberance
and emotion in one split moment when you
know oh my god i worked so hard for this
and i've gotten it by the way she could
have
really been put to the test can we get
to that position
when g took on f6 yes and you said
absolutely
i just put the engine on you'll not
believe the best move for black
is actually in this position king
d8 wow
king d8 and good luck fine
keeping the next move keeping in reserve
both captures uh
on e3 and f6 king d8
wow that is a visual move because for
the moment the knight is really off side
right mm-hmm and the best move
i'm trying different moves queen g7
fails to queen e3 check
you can't take on g7 with a pawn because
the rook
comes in and wins so or at least looks
like it wins i won't even bother
calculating this
you don't want to play this way but the
main
move the move is queen
g4
to follow queen takes on e3 with king g2
check out these geometrics you have no
more check in the position
as a knight's guarding but even then
these
these apples aren't over because here
you have the move a4 or rook
f6 even rook f6 is probably the most
natural to play
this would have been scary this would
have been scary to find but thankfully
her opponent
didn't defend with this move and instead
she was able to deliver the goods and we
see she's looking around for something
but we do have our champion irina
congratulations on winning your eighth
title
thank you guys yes i'm so happy
we saw an end moment there where you
gave a double fist pump
what does it mean to you to finally win
number eight
after four frustrating years
yeah well you know i don't again i i see
this tournament as just like a singular
event you know i don't really
think about like those uh those other
tournaments before
but i mean just you know after these
four days of play
i mean all the stress all the
preparation
i mean for it to finally end you know in
the way you want it to end what you've
been working for
i mean that just feels amazing and i'm
so happy also you know
you know um for all for all the people
that root for me that makes uh you know
it's a
very big motivating factor it's not just
for myself i mean i feel the support of
my friends
my family my students my coach i mean
all these people
that are supporting me and want you know
watching the games and hoping i'm going
to do well i want to be able to uh
to make them happy well you made a lot
of people happy
irena any any shout outs in particular
yeah yeah yeah well okay let me let me
start um
my friend irina you know she is hiking
somewhere in california now
um you know irina she's played in the
u.s women so many times and um you know
now she's a professor
um of mechanical engineering and so she
doesn't have so much time you're talking
about
yeah yeah irina zenyuk um so she's been
very supportive
um let me see who i not leave someone
out my i told i mentioned my students
you know um i have a student in china
i have students in new jersey mahathi
and my niece hello
to you guys and rama their mom
um chloe daniel
all my students and i don't know
hopefully i'm not leaving anyone out
uh brian from california from the
berkeley test school
um and you know my parents and of course
you know my coach who
has uh you know helps me win so many of
these titles and he did it again
in this tournament irina
you won three in a row but like
three excellent games in a row
it wasn't lucky it was just inspired
pressure play how were you able to
muster
up all the energy to play three games
you had to win by the way
because carissa really tested you she
kept the pace
you had to win and you found a way to
play your best chess
right when it counted in the last three
games you know yeah
again i haven't really been watching
what uh carissa was doing so i mean of
course it's true that she's been winning
her games
the good part is that i never really
noticed that because i never checked
throughout the day like yesterday i had
no idea i was in second place
you know i knew i started the game the
the day half a point ahead
you know the fact that she won two games
well i made two draws i was unaware
so i didn't you know treat the game with
tatev is like you know a must-win game
it was like
must play you got to sit down and play
some moves and you know whatever happens
happens um it of course it worked out to
be a very important win yesterday for
the standings
um and today was another big day and you
know again uh my only thought was
uh you know i'm gonna play one game and
then i'm gonna play another game
and then it's gonna end
wow you mentioned that eight you you
were
you weren't thinking about the four
before that were frustrating those were
other events they're done
but yeah you were stuck on seven and you
made no bones about it that you this
record
obviously it's it was a long time ago in
the modern age
your seven is incredible but the record
is nine
what to finally break through and get
eight as a number
you only want to weigh now what does
that mean
well first of all i think guys there was
honestly a clue that i
that i had a good chance to win this
tournament or at least i chanced like
there was a clue
if you believe in signs uh can you think
of what that was i mean did you notice
anything
anything that could have told you that
like that i would win
no tell us okay
joel won and what did joel and i have in
common
something very big brooklyn even
even more you know we uh you know we got
an email was like
it was like other than you and joel
yes because i mean we're both survivors
and in the year
in the year 2020 that's kind of a big
thing you know i mean it was sort of
like emblematic of that of this year
um and so when i saw joel win i mean out
like you know out of all these strong
players but it's like the one covet
survivor one i was like wow
interesting maybe that opens up the door
for me you know
very nice and by the way joel had a very
mild case unfortunately we know from the
coverage in the new york times and
later you gave me an interviewing ladies
night revealing that you also
suffer from what they call the long-haul
covad
so it was very different in your cases
and you know irina talk a little bit
about
how that struggle has also um you know
kind of encouraged you to
get even healthier
yeah i mean well i've been walking
every single day for like i don't know a
few months now at least i walk close to
an hour a day i feel like that's
improved my my fitness in a big way i
feel like my heart is so much better and
i mean you know i've walked when
when i breathe okay when i don't breathe
as well
like you know you just you just do it
you know um
and what i found is like okay
consistency matters a lot
you know it's like if you if you go out
rain or shine
at any time of the day and you're going
to get in your one hour walk it's going
to add up
you know um so i feel really good you
know i've lost i don't know
close to 20 pounds in the last couple of
months yeah i don't know if you guys can
tell
but it's kind of substantial and um
and uh even during this tournament
actually guys i got to my record low
weight
so you know for just another
demonstration of how stressful it is to
play chess just in like a few days
um i mean okay like i lost probably at
least like
two to three pounds i mean that's
usually something that'll take you
you know a couple of weeks to lose in
like a regular steady way you know
but it was just gone in a few days and i
mean yeah like of course
playing chess that takes a pretty big
physical toll on you
what's the secret to the reason better
just so you know jen i mean i have been
feeling better actually just around the
time of the championship started i feel
like my chest sort of loosened up and
got
like less tight and i mean you know it's
not perfect but i mean it's very
it's decent you know i'm just kind of
like i'm used to a different like
baseline of health now but
um you know i feel fortunate that it's
uh
it still permits me to to do things like
play chess oh that's fantastic to hear
irene and you know the first time you
said that i misheard you you said
your your chest loosened up and i was
like yeah you played fantastic
but you were actually referring to your
your cast
and that's not better because all the
the covet things it's all like breathing
and
chest related and those are the
remaining symptoms for so many people
um that have long long hall covid um but
yeah my
my chest uh my chest loosened up a bit
too right
i agree with you jen you're playing some
great attacking games for sure
you know that's so inspirational what
you said irina i'm sure everybody
watching
really happy for you what's the lesson
there for everyone
the the secret to resilience when
knowing that something
that bad can happen to you and you
suffer for so long what's
the secret to staying resilient
just keep going one foot in front of the
other and you you trust in better days
arm yourself with some turmeric some
honey black pepper
you know and and hope that one day
you're gonna recover and just you know
keep trying to you know do the things
that you love so
i mean i remember this uh you know one
when i got kovit i was just
back from the hospital for like uh a day
and i played jen in your in your
tournament remember it was the isolated
queens
yeah and i figured out how to shame that
yeah and i and the thing is like i mean
i was not out of the woods at all and i
mean it was still like i knew there was
a second week
coming and my illness which was like the
most dangerous and i was like
it's kind of crazy like here i am
playing chess i'm making this effort to
stream for the first time in my life
uh why am i doing this and it's like to
me it was like well if i die i want to
do
you know i want to be doing what i love
to do so that was the
that was the thinking back then and you
know yeah
wow that would be depressing but that's
just like
you know covet is a pretty serious it
was a pretty serious thing
yeah yeah you got to that point where
you really thought
you know of your own mortality it's you
know it's hard for
so many people who are huge fans of you
to even even hear that you're you're
struggling with that possibility but
i'm also glad to hear that you know
chess actually helped you through that
psychologically yeah no i mean of course
uh
and you know by the way john those
isolated queens tournaments you
organized
were some of the happiest moments of my
spring because i actually managed to do
well in them
and i would be so excited for the whole
day oh i'm so glad to hear
it and you know the thing is like just
the fact that chess can distract you i
guess is also
a beautiful thing right it it's
completely absorbing you
so that you're not thinking about
anything else right absolutely i mean
you know i played my first tournament
my first big tournament after covet in
may in the nation's cup
and i really was not even like that well
at that point you know i even during the
tournament i went to the uh
to the urgent care clinic at some point
just to check out my chest pains
but um well you know i know i mean it
was not nothing unusual it was just like
part of what i had to
you know just uh live through at that
time um
but yeah i mean chess you know i like
why can i play even like when i'm
not feeling like amazing just because
yeah it is absolutely absorbing
and i don't and when i'm playing i don't
i don't feel any problems you know you
just focus on the game
and i think thankfully you told me in
our interview for ladies night that you
worked with
um some great trainers over these last
few
months um vladimir kramnik judit pogar
anything concrete from your work in
these um
you know legendary training camps that
kind of showed up over the board
you know like right off the top of my
head jen i can't point to like a
concrete thing
you know like just like oh that idea i
learned and here i applied it
i mean i tried to play i tried to play
decent chess
i mean um like today was an interesting
moment i think in my last round game i
don't know if you guys noticed it but
when i chose to play queen g6 instead of
like queen takes c6
you know i thought the end game like
taking the pawn was pretty decent for me
um but then i was like let me just end
this game you know let me just go
for the win although it got very unclear
and i missed her move queen b5 which was
a
very good try and um and i was like i
was just completely
um terrified you know at this moment
that i was gonna mess it up and i was
kind of like very lucky it worked out
but yes i mean
i went for queen g6 and the game did end
quickly as
a result of that yeah i was just really
lucky that somehow i have all the checks
i need here that was
certainly getting worried about my own
king
um yeah i mean so
you know in terms of master classes jen
you know not only have i
attended um a number of of these classes
with great players but you know in the
last few weeks before this tournament
i actually organized a couple of them
myself i was just so inspired by
this whole concept of bringing you know
top level players um
too it's like a wider audience that i
organized a few master classes with um
with peter lico and nigel short just
leading up to this event so it was kind
of like
some nice you know um i guess a nice
chat some nice chess lessons for myself
you know that i organized this and um
and i'm actually planning to do more of
these
that was a big project that i was
working on in september leading up to
this uh this tournament
and um it worked out very nicely and
i'll be doing more of these and i
hope that um hope that we'll get more
strong players
in coming up next month well
irina you gave us your version of master
classes in these last three games
and throughout this tournament you
didn't lose a single game an incredible
plus
six out of 11 performance and you won
your eighth title
congratulations well deserved
enjoy it with all your family and
friends and we're quite happy for you as
well and the lesson for resilience
i'm sure a lot of people will be
inspired by your story thank you so much
and congrats
you did it you were the 2020 women's
champion
thank you guys can i just say thank you
to rex and jeannie who i haven't seen
here but i mean i would be remiss if i
didn't thank them
i mean for putting on this tournament
for us chess at the end of the year i
mean it didn't look like anything was
going to happen
but st louis once again once again came
through with a great event
um so thank you to them and thank you to
you guys for your amazing work i always
just
you know love to watch you thank you
thank you thanks so much enjoy
your gracious words and by the way we
are gonna oh
there's the moment um
for a 2020 u.s women's champion she's
now
an eight time champ and um by the way i
i'm pretty sure that um we're gonna have
a
uh more words from irena and all of our
champions at the uh closing ceremony
which happens after the u.s championship
so we have a combined closing ceremony
so
uh that that was just um some incredible
inspiring words from irina as she adds
a fourth name to our list of champions
we've got
carissa yip john burke joel benjamin
carissa
almost getting a double photo here but
irina
was able to seal the deal with two
beautiful victories
when she needed the most
there it is the final standings jen and
uh i i'm looking and i'm looking in
disbelief
anna zatonski many many times champion
we're
having a terrible event but carissa
yep you said it so well maurice that she
put pressure on
arena arena played great
but it really took a carissa yip to push
her
that extra mile to get that amazing
score eight and a half out of 11
very impressive gentlemen very
impressive india dorissa derek shawnee
lowest rated player in the field managed
to get the bronze medal
jennifer yu who um you know really
struggled this tournament you know kudos
to her for landing in that fourth spot
honestly i i thought
she was she was really languishing so
she had a bit of a comeback there to get
clear fourth as tatev abrahamian and
eshrita swaron
um shared fifth but hey it's all about
that
first place prize irena crush 25
000 and such an inspiring story for many
and honestly i'm so happy for her
for winning um the title but i'm also
just really happy for her that
she after months and months of battling
he's saying just before this
championship she's feeling better i mean
come on like
health is in the end the most important
thing so
um a huge smile for for my my friend
irina crush on both of those notes
coming your way soon the usgs
championship
starting on october 26th sunday we are
gonna have a rest day and then
we are gonna bring you a champion by
thursday night
marvelous our fifth and final
championship on this championship
october it's been very very special
uh throughout the broadcast of these
four days of the u.s women's
championships we've been showing you
some vintage footage of previous u.s
women's champions and i've got to tell
you guys there's some really emotional
moments and those moments of victory and
we saw
another emotive movement in 2020.
if you string those together guys it it
would definitely bring
a tear to your eyes they have been so
grateful whether it was nazi's first
win sabina winning three or three or so
months after her mother passed away
just prematurely uh certainly jen's win
as well
and the lesson that irina brought and
you know i had a
friend passed just recently sheree
robinson and i tell everyone
play like it's your last day enjoy life
like it's your last day
and it's great to see irina say you know
i got that lesson
i got that lesson and i'm loving that i
can play
and do what i love that's how you should
live life
and jennifer we uh want you to do a
countdown for us
please anna zatonski such a formidable
champion this was not her event
so she did end him last a very um
surprising finish for
such a great player but we know that she
will be back
with some strong moves in the future
as her love for chess is really eternal
and talia cervantes
who ended up tied for ninth but always a
very entertaining player
plays some really fun games uh but
she did end in that uh tie for nine as
she this was her first outing so many
more for the saint louis m
he was born in cuba but she lives there
now um sabina foyser
had some really nice wins with the white
pieces um
and she even beat ana zatonski in a
gorgeous game
but not enough wins to finish in
the top of the cross table tien tied for
nine for three thousand dollars
next up we had international master
annie wang
wow what a great start but after that he
really faded yes
as she seems to lose a number of games
and with it
maybe her confidence because you know
that annie is incredibly strong
and would normally be up there at the
top yeah it's like the wheels fell
off after the first day and she never
got the momentum back
that she needed in a tournament like
this but annie thank you so much for
your participation and all the chess
that you brought us
uh it was great watching your games
really good luck
and we had martha samadashi billy eighth
place for four thousand dollars
we saw her in the girls tournament we
also saw her in her first u.s women's
championship appearance
as she won a seat in the national girls
tournament of champions otherwise known
as the ruth harry memorial
and she uh really did put on quite a
show here
yeah very credible result eighth place
uh first outing well done
yeah we missed some of her wins but she
had some impressive ones emily nguyen
um playing and fighting hard against a
champion
in the last round and was actually tied
for second at one point in the
tournament
you know emily in the past in this
tournament she hasn't ever been there at
the top of the cross
table so expect more from this 18 year
old who just started stanford university
boy that's hard mixing a u.s women's
championship with stanford university
good luck with that but nice emily that
you uh
contested so well another great chess
player scholar
asharitha swarin her games were always
so fun and entertaining
even the one against irena which could
have changed everything in this event
she's also a great student uc berkeley
and takes home seven
thousand dollars for what started as an
awful performance but
she turned it around dying for fifth
place indeed
but well done the sharita tatev
abrahamian started out
strong but unfortunately for her she
lost the last round game to
take away her chances of finishing at
the podium um
you know fantastic uh games by tata
as always she plays so inspired but
wasn't her year
seven thousand dollars though not a bad
consolation for a tough
up and down tournament jennifer you are
defending champ who's never really in
the running for
first place but this is a very nice
finish for her considering how the rest
of the event went when she got fourth
place
10k and i think that um
she playing classical chess even
stronger than her rapid and blitz so
expect a lot more from this 18 year old
harvard freshman
absolutely and the lady who really
brought the entertainment to
this 2020 women's world champ and
women's world champion
uh u.s champion dorsa uh jen
that's right the lowest rated in the
field but fighting for first place
um completely unexpected the slough
student
takes home 13 000 for her third place
finish
well done dorset is the cat gonna get a
cut
and maybe maybe a frisky's dinner
we have international master carissa yam
three-time u.s junior girls champion
what a performance at the end she kept
irena on her toes as carissa takes home
18
000 for a fat score of 8 out of 11.
normally we would think that would be
enough for a playoff but not this time
definitely carissa congratulations
you're pushing arena
to her limits and that's what it took
jen
that's right grand master irena cruz
takes home
and her eighth u.s women's championship
title
bravo bro you know well done some great
games
some gorgeous amazing some inspiring
games
we are inspired by her moves on the
board and her
very wise words um awesome
and wow i finally i finally didn't
didn't win guys
grandmaster irina did get it done
and i got the runner-up pick as yaz and
var
great picks before the tournament but
not their best tournaments
well perfect hiding site i'm proud of
you maurice you you did good you did
good
it's so good thank you yes but i will
say
i will say that i before this tournament
i was definitely going to pick carissa
before before day one
and then when we had to lead in and then
i saw
irina's face and i looked at her and i
said
irina looks different she just
she looked different she looked so fresh
and now we found
out she lost 20 pounds uh she'd be
walking every day
she looked so well and you know and also
when i was
in introducing her with the seven
championships with all those champions
i said you know there's something that
looks really different about irina it
would
just the play the play itself and the
rating and all that went out the window
and the failures four years in a row and
i said she just looks
well and turns out that she was and
that's really great and i think that's
the most heartwarming thing of all
indeed i completely agree
hearing her say that she's finally
feeling better after
um months of battling long hail culvert
i mean that
that and the eighth championship title
you know just
keeping perspective that um health is
the most important thing in life but
absolutely you know when when you have
it and you also win a championship well
that's just um beautiful smiles
beautiful celebration
by our new champion grandmaster irena
crash
and guys it's always so fun to call this
with you even though it's not in person
this one
has been really special they're all
special ed but i agree with you
this this one was something special to
it we're
crowd and we've crowned our fourth
champion but we're not finished with
october
jen we're going to take a break one day
break i believe and we're going to be
back for the open u.s championship
invitational
open championship and that will be also
a 12-player round-robin event
and we've seen cutthroat chess already
guys
it's going to be on i'm sure
those guys are waiting in the wings like
okay okay i'll go okay that's all
it's all about my turn my journey hit me
tag me i want to get in the ring let's
go
right i can't wait for that one guys
thank you
to the entire team at st louis chess
club
of course the sing fields for sponsoring
this and
to everyone to to tom kevin
marcus um congrats on v chess to marcus
and erin
to costa sabutsuki on our twitter feeds
into varusan and kitay
um what a tm that makes this all
possible and to you both thank you so
much it's been a pleasure
working alongside you both see you guys
on monday
absolutely
[Music]
you